this video is about two things the first
is
scp-096 also known as the shy guy a
horrific monster who murders anyone and
anything unfortunate enough to look at
its face directly or through photos or
videos the second is you because we
asked you for your favorite questions
theories and hypothetical situations
involving 096 we even asked if you
thought someone would be safe from 096
on the moon and you delivered if you
haven't watched our first video on the
infamous shy guy we recommend checking
that out first but feel free to stick
around even if you haven't first of all
let's take a look at the questions you
had about the SCP foundation's most
dangerous introvert and see if we can't
find some answers how close would you
have to be to trigger it like if it was
five kilometers away would it still
count the short answer is that 096's
homicidal rage can be triggered from
pretty much any distance we'll get into
some of the potentially crazy extents of
this later on but if you see the shy
guy's face while you're sharing a
dimension with him you're in serious
trouble people who viewed the creature's
face in different countries or even
miles underwater have met gruesome ends
five kilometers would definitely not
keep you safe what were his Origins and
how strong is he compared to scp-682 the
origins of scp-096 are still shrouded in
mystery all we know for sure is that he
was discovered by the foundation in the
snowy mountainous region as for physical
durability he's about even with 682 as
both survived their encounter we know
682 has the psychological advantage
though as 096 has been terrified of the
lizard ever since they met in
cross-testing however you could argue
that 096 is technically more dangerous
since unlike 682 096 has never been
pacified before killing its intended
target while on a ramp page if he goes
into an Unstoppable Attack Mode when
someone sees his face shouldn't you not
show his face in the thumbnail
thankfully according to the official
documents artistic representations like
paintings or digitally drawn YouTube
thumbnails have no effect only actual
photographs or videos of the creature
can be deadly so you're safe unless we
decide to do a 096 face reveal to
celebrate our next 100 000 subscribers
of course this leads us to our next
question if it attacks you when you look
at it then how did the scientist draw
the picture of the thing without looking
at it that's a good question and also
one that occurred to the foundation
scientists who came up with an extremely
elaborate solution they put a d-class
tattoo artist inside a diving bell miles
underwater and had him unseal a
photograph of the creature before
drawing a copy this copy was then
released from the diving bell in the
sealed container before 096 inevitably
gone to the poor d-class does the shy
guy have to be viewed through a good
quality image to enter a rage State
unfortunately no even the most poorly
rendered or minuscule image of 096's
face is a death sentence one of the most
infamous incidents resulted from a man
seeing a small dot that was only a few
pixels wide in a photo from an old ski
trip the dot was 096 taken from a mile
away no true image of 096 is safe
regardless of size in some canons
despite 096 being referred to as
indestructible the foundation managed to
terminate it after many attempts and
even more bureaucracy how did they do it
well a lot of 096's body has been blown
away by conventional arms fire its hyper
tough skeleton is what has given it such
an indestructible reputation in one tell
though Foundation researchers actually
use this to their advantage and employed
the use of the neck snapping killer
sculpture
SCP-173 after are using 173 to damage
096's bones powerful acid was injected
into the skeleton destroying it from
within though of course this isn't the
official ending of the 096 story because
the SCP Foundation doesn't have a single
unifying cannon that's enough questions
now it's time for you to school us let's
look at some of your favorite theories
about the shy guy starting with I
sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice but he can't control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person
he starts to cry because he didn't want
to kill them there is actually some
evidence to suggest that scp-096 might
not want to kill a great example of this
is its cross test with scp-978 a camera
which reveals the deepest desires of
whoever or whatever is in its photos the
photo it took of 096 showed that it had
completely disappeared from the photo
showing its deepest desire was to just
be invisible and unseen maybe it won to
disappear because it doesn't want to
hurt anybody regarding the moon question
I think scp-096 would probably stay in
that hostile State until you came back
at which point it would promptly rip you
to shreds and do whatever it does to
your mutilated corpse based on what we
know about prior 096 incidents this
feels incredibly likely it's also
possible that it might enter its docile
State before becoming aggressive again
when you return to its murder range you
really don't want to find out either way
he can just jump to the Moon easy he
does squats and Containment all the time
while its scrawny physique doesn't make
it seem like 096 understands the concept
of exercise there aren't any cameras in
096's cell so technically we can't prove
it isn't doing squats to pass the time
in there I really doubt a blind person
would be safe from his effect since 096
has the IQ of a newborn baby I think he
will count it as looking at him this is
an interesting Theory however seeing a
096 is is able to sense when people see
its face from entire continents away the
way it knows if you can see its face
might be a little more psychic in nature
therefore it's probable that it wouldn't
mistakenly kill someone who hasn't
actually seen its face such as a person
who is blind to deal with him in my
opinion simply freeze him either in
space or in the mountains his body shuts
down and when looked at it it will not
react correctly it is simply asleep
while we don't know how scp-096 would
react to a zero-g environment for a
creature that's always nude it seems
extremely tolerant to the cold when it
was first found it was lurking in icy
mountains and a foundation agent
commented on the fact it wasn't even
shivering despite the incredibly low
temperatures but who knows if there's a
temperature out there that's too low
even for the shy guy if someone looks at
it in China and it's in the U.S then you
get on its back you'll get a free
piggyback ride to China it's a free trip
to China and all it costs is a human
life that's my Theory technically it'd
be at the cost of two human lives unless
you wore a diving suit with plenty of
oxygen 096 has proven to be an extremely
proficient swimmer but you'd have to
maintain your grip across the entire
Pacific Ocean while it Journeys to China
in other words it's technically possible
but we here at SCP explained would
rather pay for the round-trip flight to
each their own though but that's enough
theories for now let's move on to the
main event
hypotheticals you pose some great
possible scenarios involving
scp-096 so we're going to see if we can
find the answers what would happen if
someone looked at a picture of it while
in or before entering another scp's
pocket Dimension or mirror Dimension
there aren't any Canon examples to prove
either way but if there's any kind of
consistent entry point into this
Dimension it's likely that 096 would
find a way to follow you in if not it's
very possible that it may just wait for
you to eventually return before bringing
the metaphorical hammer down on you so
technically if you were pulled into the
old man's pocket Dimension and he closed
the portal you'd be safe from 096 but
then you've got a whole other problem to
deal with what happens if a person sees
his face and gets their memory of the
creature white considering how good the
foundation seems to be at wiping
people's memories and their access to
amnestics if this worked they probably
would have made it standard procedure by
now so it's unlikely what happens if a
person looked at it and that person then
went on a plane or just staying in the
air or space what would it do 096 has
shown the ability to jump up and Destroy
low-flying aircraft but otherwise it's
likely that the creature would probably
run to a point directly below you and
remain there until you touch back down
since you'll need food and water at some
point and aircrafts need fuel you'd
probably just be prolonging the
inevitable what if the young girl was
around it so it tried to attack her but
died trying this is another interesting
possibility
scp-053 is a girl capable of causing
homicidal urges but causes fatal heart
attacks in those who attack her while we
can't know for sure how a meeting
between 096 and 053 would go we can use
her encounter with 682 as a potential
template aggressive scps like the hard
to kill reptile perhaps having an innate
knowledge of the danger that comes from
attacking 0-5-3 tend to become strangely
docile around her it's possible that 096
would do the same would we be able to
control scp-096 with the help of scp-035
the possessive mask AKA
scp-035 is undeniably a lot more
intelligent than 096 and has even been
shown to respond to reason on occasion
it's also been able to control almost
every other entity it's been placed on
the problem is if the mass was placed on
096 and it was somehow effective the
result may be even more dangerous than
096 an intelligent monster with an
indestructible and highly dangerous body
there's no telling whether 035 would
slowly break down 096 into sludge the
way it does to humans in which case we
would be left with an immortal
096035 combo so maybe it's best that we
never find out if someone were to be in
the infinite Ikea and looked at the
picture of its face could it finally be
contained and if someone else looked at
a picture of it outside of the infinite
Ikea could it escape and kill them if so
how long would it take it this is a
great question and while the infinite
Ikea is a terrifying maze
scp-096 has an advantage here that we
don't not only can It Rip through
anything in the way with its super
strength it has an innate sense of where
its victim is therefore regardless of
whether you're in side or out
scp-096 will still come straight to you
to exact your horrible fate but at least
you can enjoy the meatballs while you
wait right and finally what would happen
if 096 were led into a room full of
mirrors and a loud or made to look at
its own face Would It smash the mirrors
or try to rip itself to pieces this is
still a hotly debated issue to this day
which thanks to the no Canon nature of
the SCP Foundation does not have a
definitive answer some theorize that
this would at least be an effective
deterrent against
scp-096 While others suggest that it
wouldn't be effective because many
believe that 096 is actually blind and
thus cannot see its own face it can only
sense when other people see it again we
don't quite know for sure but it's
likely to remain one of the most
contentious issues around the shy guy
for a long time to come and there you
have it folks our very first questions
and theories video we loved hearing what
you had to say so keep an eye on our
community post for the next one are
there other scps you'd like to see us
cover and explained or Theory videos let
us know in the comments we were a team
despite our differences
spite of the Terrible Things they've
done
we were still a team that's not how the
higher up saw it though
no
the guys upstairs with their perfectly
pressed shirts for them we were judged
by our level of expendability and they
knew that our next mission was a death
sentence
one by one that thing took out my team
my friends
snapping their necks so quickly and with
such ease that no sooner did I hear the
scream
they were dead
we had been used I'd been used
delivered as prey to the predator
a plot that was sanctioned by the bosses
and approved with a blood red stamp
why do they do it
I'm still trying to figure that out
maybe that's something you can tell me
after you hear how these so-called
scientific men left us in the cell
and in the hands of SCP-173
for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times
the best because I'd quickly risen
through the ranks of the facility
the worst because well
I was never the best student I finished
high school by the skin of my teeth and
my job prospects looked Bleak but I was
lucky I guess or at least I thought so
at the time
you see I have an uncle Siegfried who
did some work for the government I never
actually knew what he did just thought
it was secretive work
I used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
I was when he found out I needed a job
and he offered to help me out
waiver I always thought he hated me
and overheard him telling my parents
that I was a no-good deadbeat but now he
had a change of heart and was willing to
take me under his wing
but what I got to do undercover
intelligence gathering
International assassinations
just you wait he said
and that's how I found myself walking
into a sprawling futuristic looking
facility where they handed me a level
one security clearance card with big
bold letters that read
janitor but I was happy just the words
security clearance made me feel
important and it beat flipping burgers
I push mops turned off lights fired up
generators clocked in and clocked out
but all that time they must have been
washing me grooming me waiting for the
day they could throw me to the wolves
I should have known
I've always been an Expendable kind of
guy after a few years I was called to an
office there was a man in a plaid shirt
and kind of a tweed jacket that
professors wear
he asked me do you have any idea about
what we actually do here
and to be honest
I didn't I knew that there were many
parts of the facility I couldn't enter I
imagine that down a maze of corridors
were weapons being built with prisoners
being interrogated but I had no idea
about the anomalies
how could I before I was told anything I
had to sign a bunch of forms there were
so many I thought I'd get to find out
who really killed JFK
and while they didn't come out and say
it what I inferred was that if I ever
talk about what happens at the facility
to someone outside the facility well
let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves bad it sells and
Rusty tools
I wasn't scared though
I was part of something big something
Secret
and I loved it so I signed my life away
with no hesitation soon after I was
introduced to my first anomaly the safe
class of course
they took me to an observation room from
that room I could see into another room
with a sign on the wall that read as
cp067 I just stood there waiting for
something to happen when in walked
another guy in a white platco welcome to
your first anomaly he said is it okay if
I hook you up to this heart monitor we
want to gauge your reaction to what you
see
all I can see I told them is an empty
room with a table in what looks like a
pen on top of some papers
correct we said half smiling as if I was
some kind of idiot that's
scp-067 I thought about telling him that
if I needed years of train before I
could see a pen that I probably should
have taken that fast food job could have
been a shift manager by now
then they brought a young chimpanzee
into the room small enough to be
harmless one of the guys forced to pen
into the scared chimp's hand and
something strange happened
started scribbling nonsense at first but
suddenly it was sketching and drawing
faster and faster I could catch glimpses
of words and images by the time they
dragged it out it was flailing around
like it was possessed that pen has power
said the man in the lab coat a power
whose Source or origin we don't fully
understand
that's why we're here that's why you are
here one of the guys in the other room
held The Chimps drawing up to the window
it was a perfect sketch of the Tower of
London intricate and brilliant
above the sketch was the title Tower of
London Tudor period Circa 1541 the year
Margaret Pohl the Countess of Salisbury
lost her head on The Chopping Block
underneath that the chimp had written
pity she was no traitor take it from me
I was there they didn't need to look at
the heart rate monitor to see that I was
shocked
that was far from the only anomaly I'd
come into contact with and I must have
been doing something right because in
time I went from Level 1 to 2 to level 3
security clearance and that's when they
made me a containment specialist I won't
bore you with all the details but as you
can guess I dealt with the containment
of anomalies a lot of my time was spent
looking through small windows and cell
doors making sure that whatever was
inside was still inside and still in one
piece
other times I worked with field agents
when anomalies were brought in the
transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like there was one
certain anomaly though that I was tasked
to oversee on many occasions I like to
think of it as my pet
but in hindsight I was its pet
this was
SCP-173 something that was in what we
call the Euclid class the classification
meaning that we don't fully understand
it but no it is very dangerous
we know it's intelligent we know it's
unpredictable and we know it will kill
and for that reason there's people
tasked with containing it and keeping an
eye on it at all times
at first glance you wouldn't guess just
how dangerous 173 is you wouldn't think
it's incredibly intelligent in fact
you'd think the opposite that's because
it's more or less a walking slab of
concrete and rebar with stunted Limbs
and traces of spray paint that give the
impression of a Dopey face we have to
enter itself twice a week for cleaning
duties it leaves a disgusting foul
smelling liquid on the floor a reddish
brown substance that I can only describe
as a mix of blood and waste products
where that stuff comes from has remained
a mystery since we first contained it in
1993.
going into the cell was always a
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173. can't move
if human eyes are watching it that's why
you need at least two people watching it
at all times if you're in the room
watching 173 by yourself and blinked
you'd be dead before your eyes open we
don't know how it moves that fast but in
that fraction of a second your neck is
snapped so hard it's almost like being
decapitated I've seen the videos to
prove it all it took was a sneeze he
wasn't even finished getting the rest of
the achoo out when there was a Flash and
his partner was left lying on the ground
his head twisted around the wrong
direction so you can understand why we
now require three men for any time we
must enter 173 South
then a few months ago I was told that a
long process would begin to train and
re-educate some future class D's
class D's are mostly prisoners with
lifelong sentences or those we've taken
from death row and given a new lease on
life we were apparently understaffed so
why not employ these men whose lives had
pretty much ended anyway that was the
rationale or at least that's what they
told me I was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173's mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
specialist could focus on more important
tasks
they hadn't been through the training I
had seen what I had seen But after
showing them the video of 173 nearly
taking off a man's head they were more
than willing to follow the rules they
understood not to Blink or turn away or
sneeze and that any lapse in Focus could
lead to a violent death so I started to
show them the robes how we move as a
team into the cell and always keep the
others informed on what we're doing
173 was always sitting in the corner of
a cell no expression on that crude face
but when we walked in itself I got the
feeling it knew something had changed
I felt almost as if it was communicating
with me but I couldn't tell what it was
trying to say
then it happened
it was a Tuesday afternoon three days
from the last time we cleaned as usual
173 had covered the floor with that
horrible liquid we headed in to clean my
new team alert as always and some of
them cleaned While others kept their
eyes focused on the thing in the corner
things were going smoothly when we heard
a noise I knew very well
it was the sound of the cell door
locking
someone must have screwed up hey guys
we're locked in here I shot it through
the intercom nothing guys the damn door
is locked
nothing
I lost it a bit open the door will you
my team looked at me the ones not on eye
contact Duty that is as if I should know
what to do hoping that this had happened
before and that there was some kind of
standard plan to deal with it
there wasn't
we were always observed when in the room
and I knew that a technician couldn't
accidentally lock the door it was
impossible there were protocols someone
had done this on purpose
the four of us sat in the corner of the
room as far from 173 as possible our
eyes locked on it it didn't move an inch
as usual just stood staring at the wall
as it always did
we stayed awake through the night
talking a little holding on to the slim
hope that something had gone wrong
but as night turned today again we all
began to lose hope we weren't sent here
to clean
you were a test totally expendable
Lab Rats but I wouldn't go down without
a fight we couldn't just stay up forever
that was a death sentence I suggested
that two of us stand one sit and rest
and one get some sleep
we take shifts couple hours on a couple
hours off
maybe we could show that we wouldn't
give up they'd have time to realize what
they were doing was insane call off the
test and come free us
we made it through a couple of shifts
like this and it seemed like we'd
actually be able to make it another day
or two when everything went wrong
it was my turn to sit and rest when I
heard the worst possible noise
snoring
the con next to me was sleeping quietly
so it must be one of the standards I
glanced over for just a split second and
saw both of them leaning against the
cell wall dozing at the same time I saw
the flash crack snap pop
one after another their necks were
snapped I'm not sure how it happened but
I was standing again staring at 173 who
was now in the corner dead bodies with
their heads twisted around piled up in
front of it
I couldn't take it anymore I couldn't
stare at this thing forever I felt
myself giving up I lowered my head to
the ground and then finally broke my
gaze ready to die
and then
nothing happened I slowly raised my head
back up and there it was it's hideous
face inches away from mine it was then
that I understood what we'd been
containing but we'd underestimated
I felt it again like it was telling me
something
was telling me to close my eyes to sleep
so I did but as my eyes closed I didn't
see Darkness
I saw 173 or something like it but not
in the cell
I saw it outside in the world standing
over children sleeping in the beds
watching
I saw them hiding in the shadows
staring out at passersby
and I realized they weren't watching
waiting to pounce
no they were hiding
my eyes popped open as the door opened
and in Rush Six security personnel
they took me outside jabbed my leg with
a syringe injecting me with something as
the world faded
away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with euclid-class anomaly
SCP-173
subject has cease responding to external
stimuli and appears to have taken on the
traits and behaviors of the anomaly
subject now spends entire day sitting in
corner of cell staring at the wall
staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with subject as the
only Behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
Effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever as you walk down the
halls of the SCP Foundation site 19
speaking in the various windows that the
anomalies contained there you might
catch a glimpse of a dark figure bent
over a table tinkering away like an
artisan in his Workshop a vintage black
Apothecary bag sits next to him open and
if you stop and watch for a while you'll
see him pull all manner of tools out of
it impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an IV stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly Folk singularly on his craft
whatever that might be only one thing
could distract him from his efforts you
he feels your Gaze on him and he looks
up dark eyes glittering from behind a
beaked ceramic mask he reminds you of an
illustration you once saw in a book
about the Black Death the gear the
plague doctors wore while treating
patients on their deathbeds hello he
greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkled beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear fellow are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand and you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
hell I can examine you he offers Palm
press flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work
table back and forth listening to the
sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morgue
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden away pieces
of the corpses tissue samples and jars
of formaldehyde you could pull out when
the monotony became too much but the
days of fresh materials of enlightened
discourse with other men and women of
science were over how we missed those
days the chance to work with others as
he once had what had he done wrong all
he did was treat the sick sure they
didn't always understand their illness
didn't want to receive their medicine
but that wasn't a choice for the patient
to make that should have been up to the
physician perhaps they didn't trust his
expertise then see how his work served
the greater good like those who watched
Jonas Salk invent the polio vaccine or
Louis Pasteur red milk of bacteria they
were confused by the advanced scientific
practices and feared that which they did
not understand he could forgive them for
their ignorance he was magnanimous that
way if only they would let him out of
this infernal room he could prove his
work's Worth to them he could cure them
all began a era of wellness and peace
worldwide he didn't exactly sleep but
when he rested on his little cot in the
corner of the room he dreamed of that
future of a world healed by his touch a
knock at the door stirred him from his
reverie someone someone was at the door
of his containment cell he glanced at
the little window and saw a guard there
with a tray of food he greeted the man
with an enthusiastic wave
he didn't require the food for survival
of course but it helped his mind work
more efficiently it reminded him of a
time before these fluorescent lights and
these same Four Walls of crusty bread
with fresh butter by the banks of the
Sun the little slot opened in the door
and the tray was shoved through there
was bread just as he hoped a small dish
of butter pot of jam and a cup of tea
still seeming he picked up the cup at
first taking a deep breath ah an herbal
blend with fresh lavender lovely he
couldn't see the guard through the
window anymore but he called out to him
just the same thank you for the
Libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he
could have gotten a better look at the
man seen the power of His complexion a
Tremor in his hand he thought he had
spotted sweat beating on his forehead
could he be ill the case required
further examination to be certain he
sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him
why must they scream at the sight of his
efforts flee from his instruments it
didn't seem fair still the pursuit of
science rarely was a glamorous one he
had learned as much over the centuries
one day though history would look back
on him kindly of this he could be
certain he was just settling in and
beginning to spread butter across the
admittedly stale bread when a horrible
sound shook him to attention he had
heard the noise before though he had
never seen its source it was an
ear-splitting scream a whale of pure
Agony like the sound of a wounded wild
animal he had heard many many screams
during his life from patience and those
who stood in the way of his work but
until he had been brought into custody
of the foundation he had never heard a
scream quite like this one it was pure
rage Devastation and suffering mixed
together wet with tears and loud enough
to rip through human vocal holds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain of
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thought of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the Halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire for The Gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darting past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as Flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he studied himself and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
Damage Done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
Chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open while
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood Stark and Vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely Pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet here save for
one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to
the wall was a pale thin figure it
shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs this poor soul was clearly in great
distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white distended arms
wrapped around itself as a cried excuse
me the doctor cried out to the pitiful
creature are you all right do you need
assistance he didn't answer it just
continued to cry had something so
despondent been responsible for this
destruction the dozens of corpses the
smashed in walls the crumbled doors and
shattered Windows it seemed impossible
sure it was large and looked strong but
he had never seen a monster cry before
this couldn't be a dangerous creature
not when it was so sad he would help it
but first he would attend to some of
these bodies he sat his bag on the
ground pulled out several vials of
liquid a set of syringes and a variety
of other surgical tools he might need
now after such a long Hiatus he could
resume his work in a meaningful way he
couldn't be certain how long he worked
Reviving these poor souls and
reconstructing their bodies as the pale
creature wept in the corner the sobbing
faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he
removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his Suffering
The Corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open an eyeball dangling unseen from
the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide impossibly wide and a treat
that same terrible sound as before tears
streamed from its colorless eyes its
arms shaking with unbridled rage has its
jaws locked around the patient's head
like a boa construct in one fluid motion
it swallowed the revived man whole while
the doctor watched in shock he had been
wrong this was not an innocent creature
caught in the wrong place at the wrong
time this creature whatever it was was
deeply sick he had never seen such an
advanced aggressive case of the
pestilence he'd heard rumors of course
but never encountered it firsthand as a
doctor he had sworn to do no harm but in
a drastic situation drastic measures
have to be taken it was well known by
himself and the doctors at this
Foundation that he could cause any and
all biological functions in an organism
to cease with a single touch and so he
approached the creature arm outstretched
ready to administer that necessary touch
to protect the rest of his patients as
he approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of Tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a Breakneck speed I am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the Beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thud the doctor paced around the Fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still Rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious
very curious indeed he muttered perhaps
there were comorbidities present other
infections aside from the pestilence
which rendered the creature unnaturally
strong resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell it required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistance to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risked
Discovery and subsequent Interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an IV stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
be held out of hand and his favorite
surgical blade was placed in it by one
of the helpful patients thank you he
slid the scalpel along the hairline of
the creature or where the hairline would
be if it weren't completely bald once
the scalp was removed he set it aside
for later when it could be reattached
bonsa please he held out his hand again
and again his assistant gave him the
proper tool this however was when things
got strange the doctor had always been a
Deft hand at cutting he'd once even
received tutelage from the great Robert
system but no matter how hard he tried
to saw it never left a scratch on the
creature's skeleton naturally this was
somewhat frustrating he wanted to study
the creature's brain tissue to get a
sense for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creature's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he'd learn while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
Egyptians he produced a long curved Hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes do all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place it was mid-stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming gun at his face excuse me
I am in surgery at the moment please do
not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or lower his
weapon in fact he shouted something into
the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into
the skull of the patient standing at his
side how dare you the doctor cried
readying himself to confront the guard
but it was too late dozens of other
guards were swarming the room and
neutralizing his assistance summon
hazmat suits grabbed his arms and pulled
him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he
fought or how loudly he protested then
something incredible happened something
wonderful the creature opened its eyes
and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one
another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared Placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing in flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole I did it the doctor
shouted overcome with Elation I've cured
you now Begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive Containment
Breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards but the staff
agreed not to tell scp-049 about any of
this better to just let him have this
one he really seemed like he needed a
win a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon
sounds more like what you'd find in the
back room of a craft store or a
forgotten closet than a mysterious
creature worthy of investigation and yet
that's exactly what scp-066 appeared to
be or at least it did at first glance
but the SCP Foundation doesn't contain
and study just anything and there was
and still is something incredibly
strange just below the surface of
scp-066 also known as Eric's toy at
first Eric's toy seemed to be completely
harmless and even helpful a knot of
string that produced strange but
harmless items and effects but the
foundation soon discovered a dark side
to scp-066 while it may be referred to
as a toy this is no mere plaything
scp-066 weighs only about one kilogram
and appears to be a braided bunch of
yarn and ribbon though there is no
apparent musical capability within the
strands of yarn and ribbon themselves
music can be produced by moving
individual strands one at a time when it
was first being studied this SCP was
composed of multi-colored strings and
ribbons but it has since undergone a
transformation and now presents an
appearance somewhat different from its
initial description the strands of yarn
and ribbon can be used to play the notes
of a diatonic scale c d e f g a b though
the research has not been able to
determine just how scp-066 produces
music or any sound at all
scp-066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066-2 its classification was
adjusted to a subcategory of Euclid
Euclid impetus Euclid is a
classification given to scps that are
more difficult to contain than those
classified as safe impetus in Latin
means attack and specifies that scp-066
is not only Euclid class but on the more
aggressive side while 066 is not always
aggressive towards humans the events of
incident 066-2 prove that it is highly
unpredictable and should not be provoked
like many scps it proved that
underestimating its capabilities can be
a dangerous mistake before the incident
scp-066 displayed only Charming if
unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strengths
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility and what about
their work with the light-hearted
Carefree Spirit after playing an
improvised six note Melody with the
strands a researcher was thrilled to
find that scp-066 was capable of
shape-shifting its appearance changed to
resemble a small calico kitten for 17
minutes the kitten was incredibly
friendly rubbing its head against the
researcher's glove hand and purring
loudly ironically enough the kitten also
spent time playing with a piece of
string after the 17 minutes were up the
kitten transformed back into
scp-066's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
Melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the SCP then played a four-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the SCP he was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
scp-066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings against the
warning of his peers the assistant ate
the cupcake in response the SCP played
the rest of happy birthday and the
assistant suffered no adverse effects
from the cupcake all this fun was
brought to a swift end when one
scientist suggested that a portion of
scp-066's yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested on April 18 2008 the event that
would become known as incident 066-2
took place
a Young Man known only as
d-066-4437 or D was assigned to the task
naturally he was a member of the highly
disposable d-class Personnel but Dee was
grateful for the opportunity as most
experiments of a similar nature involved
quite a bit more obvious risk it was a
simple enough job take a pair of
scissors snip off some yarn and bring it
back to the lab for further study
it was hardly on the level of
supervising 173 or being 682's latest
chew toy
he entered the containment room where
scp-066 was lying dormant in still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the SCP rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop one meter
away where it started to make a
high-pitched squeaking sound resembling
The Cry of a frightened rabbit unsure
what to do and unprepared for this
scenario D approached the entity again
he snagged another Fistful of yarn and
cut only for zero six six to curl into a
ball and roll away from him again even
faster this time once it was safely on
the other side of the room and away from
the scissors it stopped moving only this
time it didn't squeak
instead for the very first time since
its containment it spoke in a deep
uncannily human voice and asked are you
Eric after recovering from his initial
shock at hearing a voice come out of a
massive string D responded no I'm not
this answer said something off in
scp-066 and its form began to shift and
change the string wriggled around on the
floor unbraiding and wrapping around
itself into a mound the colors
previously a rainbow of Shades shifted
until every strand was a blood red much
to D's horror the transformation was not
yet complete small bumps began to emerge
from the spaces between the strands of
yarn popping out all over the bright red
Mass if that wasn't terrifying enough
suddenly all together as one they
blinked open revealing themselves to be
over a dozen small eyes every single eye
was focused at D studying him staring
him down
scp-066 then began to produce loud
abrupt dissonant notes like someone
banging on the keys of a piano D had
seen enough he abandoned his task and
fled the containment room after this
failed attempt to attract a sample
scp-066's behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began
to change dramatically before the
incident the SCP was largely dormant
only becoming active if a melody was
played using its strands following the
incident and its change of form 066
began to move on its own long strands of
its yarn body would move like tentacles
writhing and wriggling around at high
speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the site
of any human regardless of the human's
Behavior the SCP would begin to react
with sound and effect within 6 seconds
the first of these effects was noted by
a research assistant who entered the
scp's containment facility a week after
the incident with d as she approached
066 to take notes about its current
state and its new ability to move a b
appeared out of nowhere it stung the
assistant and flew away before it could
be captured Weeks Later a team of 11
personnel were monitoring the SCP when
it suddenly burst into a rendition of
Beethoven's Second Symphony It produced
this music at a volume of over 140
decibels permanently deafening three of
the personnel and causing permanent
hearing damage in the other egg it was
theorized that the SCP did this as an
act of Retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these Personnel refused to
work with scp-066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor The Entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room was dark and there was
a complete loss of visibility the lights
were unable to be turned on for five
hours and any attempt at an alternate
light source such as a flashlight was
unsuccessful it was as if the darkness
in the room swallowed any and all light
right up it was similar to the
oppressive Darkness within scp-087 or
the unlimited black of
scp-3001's Shadow Dimension the person
now in the room later reported hearing
the sound of loud labor breathing just
behind their shoulders though when they
searched for a source of the sound they
could find nothing there had been no
recent anomalies reported or any
additional hostile Behavior instead
whenever it sees a new human
scp-066 repeats the name Eric again and
again in the same deep voice
who is Eric no one at the facility knows
or if they do they have not reported it
to any official channels it is possible
that the SCP was once owned by someone
named Eric and perhaps given the
circumstances under which scp-066 first
said the name Eric attempted to cut the
threads of the entity while it was in
his care unfortunately there are no
official records of how scp-066 was
discovered or why it was brought to the
foundation in the first place its
Origins remain murky and as mysterious
as everything else about it all that is
known is that whoever Eric is
scp-066 is determined to find him once
the scp's class was changed from safe to
Euclid its containment procedures had to
be adjusted while it was previously kept
in a simple room it is now contained in
a Tungsten Carbide box at its site's
high value item storage facility once a
month the box is inspected for damage to
its interior due to the scp's tendency
to use its appendages to wear Down the
Walls of the box over time
if there is any damage
scp-066 is to be moved to a new box
using a robotic arm that performs this
transfer in less than three seconds the
foundation has attempted to place
recording devices in the box with the
entity in order to monitor Its Behavior
when there are no humans present but the
SCP destroys every recording device
placed inside of its containment box and
any attempts to record Its Behavior when
it is not being observed by humans have
been unsuccessful whatever it's doing
when there is no one around it wants to
keep a secret on the surface
scp-066 is one of the less frightening
finds contained within the walls of the
SCP Foundation it does not have claws or
teeth or the ability to cause Mass
deaths but it has incredible
unpredictable capabilities and seems
very capable of holding a grudge there
is so much that is unknown about it from
its Origins to its form to its ability
to manifest matter from nothing
there is something deeply unsettling
about this scp's unpredictable behavior
and increased hostility towards being
observed we do not know what it has done
and we do not know what it will do next
all we can do is blunder it as we Ponder
the nature of scp-066 it does nothing
but sit staring with unblinking eyes
waiting for Eric to come back not all
heroes wear caves some of them wear
Pokemon t-shirts and a baseball cap you
might think you've heard of every
superhero out there with Marvel and DC
dominating the box office and the
incredible cactus man fighting crime on
the Mean Streets of Edinburgh but there
is one tiny aspiring hero you'd likely
never heard of in a world filled with
danger and evildoers one young boy armed
with a pure heart and some telekinetic
Powers dared to step up and save the day
a woman was being abducted at gunpoint
when seven-year-old Cameron spotted the
struggle he saw the weapon in the the
man's hand the fear in the woman's eyes
as she looked for a way out and he knew
that he had to act he concentrated with
all his might reaching out with his mind
and threw the gun out of the man's grasp
and into some nearby bushes the woman
ran as fast as she could from there but
not before catching a glimpse of the
child that had saved her life somehow
she knew that he had been her hero
unfortunately for Cameron but
fortunately for the SCP Foundation the
woman reported what had happened to a
nearby police officer who just so
happened to be an undercover agent for
the foundation before Cameron could
leave the scene he was being approached
by a team of armed guards and brought to
a strange new place filled with men in
lab coats who kept calling him
scp-2241 Cameron sat for a very long
time in a white room wondering whether
he was in trouble when a new man in a
lab coat entered he introduced himself
as researcher Valdez and told Cameron he
was going to ask him some questions he
asked why Cameron had helped the woman
instead of running away and getting an
adult to help he said Superheroes have
to help people I can move things without
touching them and other people can't so
I should have used that to help them he
went on to explain that he had practiced
his ability in the woods and kept it a
secret from everyone Valdez asked what
sort of things Cameron could do and he
explained I can move stuff without
touching it but not if it's too far away
or if it's too big only like a cup
across the room or a person's arm or
something sometimes I it can sort of
change as well when prompted he
elaborated sometimes when I'm moving
something it changes to something I want
like one time when I was moving a stone
it changed to look like a toy I lost but
it changed back after a while before I
even got home Cameron became distressed
during the interview but Valdez promised
him that he would be okay here he asked
Cameron what his superhero name would be
and he told him Cameron the Crusader
Valdez explain that Cameron would be
staying at the SCP Foundation for a
while so they could learn more about his
powers and help him become a better
superhero researcher Valdez concluded
his interview with this closing
statement
scp-2241 appears to trust me and
believes that the foundation is
attempting to help him as much as
possible
scp-2241's account is consistent with
the early stages of humanoid developing
a reality bending ability
scp-2241 may have experienced abuse at
the hands of its parents leading to
early development of set ability in the
event that a more developed ability is
required for research similar emotional
stress can be applied by Foundation
staff
scp-2241 is kept in a standard humanoid
containment chamber he is given access
to television and comic books though
this access can be cut off as punishment
for bad behavior he has fed three
balanced meals a day with additional
treats such as chocolate or ice cream
provided after testing especially if the
testing goes on for a particularly long
time or is exceptionally stressful all
Personnel that interact with scp-2241
are to call him by his name Cameron when
interacting with him only Cameron's
assigned psychologist and specifically
designated Personnel such as Valdez are
allowed to develop a friendly
relationship with him if he becomes
attached to an unapproved person they
are required to discourage this however
they can after containment procedures
were established Valdez and his team set
to work putting together tests that
would use Cameron's emotions and desires
to save people in order to develop and
strengthen his abilities for the first
test they deliberately exposed Cameron
to a d-class that believed him to be a
valuable hostage one that he could use
to escape from the foundation the
d-class abducted Cameron at knife point
but Cameron quickly used his reality
bending ability to turn the knife into
chocolate and escape the knife remained
chocolate and did not turn back to metal
indicating his power hours had grown
stronger details of events that followed
this test have been redacted from the
official file but a note from a member
of the OverWatch Council provides a peek
into what might have happened
scp-2241 has stated that it intends to
grow stronger to stop more people from
dying and this will help both it and Us
in this aim killing a man with a
teleported bullet was a stroke of
tactical genius from the SCP object MTF
Theta 17 will be ready to respond during
all further rounds of testing as a
precaution following a series of tests
Each of which included heightened
emotional Stakes such as threatening the
lives of innocent bystanders or
treasured items belonging to scp-2241
his abilities developed even further in
one test a series of armed drones were
made to artificially malfunction posing
an apparent threat to Foundation
Personnel around the boy he responded by
using his telekinesis to turn the drones
on each other crashing them into one
another while only one drone remained he
teleported its Weaponry to a nearby
Field leaving a harmless shell behind in
another test a bomb was detonated near a
member of d-class personnel the boy
somehow absorbed the energy of the bomb
as it exploded transforming its kinetic
energy and saving the man's life another
bomb related test featured man with a
bomb strapped to him attacking a d-class
in this test it was ordered that the
bomber be taken alive Cameron responded
by teleporting the bomb vest into an
explosion-proof containment chamber and
knocking the bomber unconscious with a
single punch though his tiny fish should
not have been capable of delivering such
a strong blow in another test a third
bomb was placed in
scp-2241's chamber among his personal
belongings including some stuffed
animals and comic books he was very
upset at this discovery and teleported
the bomb high up into the sky where it
detonated harmlessly he remained upset
for a while after repeating no one can
take my things it's not fair there I'm
strong I'm the Crusader moving on from
bombs the research team tasked the boy
with stealing a box from a foundation
bank vault which had been modified for
extra security he teleported himself
into the Vault picked up the box and
then made a mistake he tripped the
sensors inside however he somehow slowed
the sensors down and was able to
teleport himself back out of the Vault
before the alarm could sound this was
the first task given to Cameron that
could be perceived as morally gray or
even villainous but he performed it
without question and this was recorded
as a notable development next a surprise
long-range attack was performed on the
foundation Side by a foundation-owned
robotic mortar 2241 became angry
catching the bomb and throwing it toward
the launcher at a speed that appeared to
be approximately 1.4 times the speed of
sound it was noted that his abilities
were less focused and his demeanor more
violent when he was angry he turned to
an observing researcher and said I hate
them I'm a foundation Avenger and I hate
the bad guys and I'm gonna fight them
all for the final test in this series 2D
classes were described to 2241 as
civilians were held at gunpoint in rooms
with bulletproof glass windows he was
told that the guns could not be affected
by his powers the hostages needed
physical contact to be teleported to
safety and he needed to rescue them both
before they were killed shocking the
research team he split into two versions
of himself each teleporting a hostage to
safety before returning to the crime
scene to subdue the bad guys he reported
feeling a bit sick afterwards but had no
other adverse effects from splitting
himself into two people by the time this
series of tests were completed he was
able to teleport objects as well as his
own body duplicate himself see a few
seconds into the future and move or
transform objects within a distance of
12 meters he was excited about these
improvements referring to them as
leveling up following these tests Valdez
plan to pause the psychiatric treatment
of scp-2241 in favor of a more Hands-On
approach the plan was to begin
neurological testing using a surgically
implanted chip that would monitor the
boy's brain activity during combat the
Ethics Committee caught wind of this and
immediately intervened they temporarily
revoked valdez's security clearance and
placed him under investigation they
submitted an official report on this
decision which read implanting a
monitoring chip into a child this young
cannot be done without significant
developmental damage in later years this
will cause catastrophic problems for
both the child and long-term containment
given his well-developed capabilities
additionally deploying a child in combat
even under testing conditions violates
all moral Norms Personnel involved in
sweeping the previous rapid-fire tests
under the rug are under review the
testing and research surrounding
scp-2241 did not only draw the attention
of the Ethics Committee but it also
caused Discord within the OverWatch
Council itself following the Ethics
Committee intervention 05-3 ordered that
testing be resumed writing these tests
are more important than one SCP
regardless of whether it looks like
ankinda long-term containment and
observation is no longer a priority
given the utility of data we have
collected via intensive testing in the
short term the risk of the SCP breaching
containment is minimal given its loyalty
we now know which parts of the brain
deal with certain anomalous abilities
with small detail we can see how we may
even learn how to induce these abilities
and we will definitely learn how to
neutralize them to other members of the
council were horrified by this statement
believing that it won against decency
and morality in a way that could not be
justified o5-4 submitted a statement
this is too far we cannot let this stand
as president this is but one step
removed from Child soldiers and even
less removed from militarizing an SCP
level object an emergency Council May
meeting was called to address this
internal disagreement and the majority
voted in favor of reinstating testing
and exonerating Valdez of all ethics
violations I believe the results will
Justify both the risks and the means
we're closer than ever to understanding
the mechanism by which human brains
interact with extra normal phenomena the
emotional and eventual neurological
damage to scp-2241 is unfortunate but it
is also necessary for the advancement of
our understanding in addition due to the
new modification of the monitoring
Hardware 2241 can be neutralized quickly
should it become a threat at any time
after the surgery and so the protests of
the Ethics Committee were ignored the
concerned members of the OverWatch
Council overruled and Valdez was allowed
to resume his plan for testing and
preparing to craft a super-powered child
into a weapon and all the while a little
boy named Cameron remained the test
subject of the SCP Foundation still
dreaming of the day when he might have a
chance to save the world over the past
several years many of us have learned
how incredibly life-threatening and
dangerous viruses and diseases can be
they can cause any number of critical
symptoms and can shut down your body's
processes in a wide variety of ways but
there are more diseases than just the
ones we can name off the top of our
heads based on recent experience many of
these have nothing anomalous about them
despite being incredibly strange take
Progeria it's a genetic condition that
causes people carrying a very specific
gene mutation to age rapidly not twice
as fast either so fast that most victims
tragically don't live past their early
teens or elephantiasis if you're
thinking that's a disease affecting
elephants you'd be wrong but not grossly
so it causes the lymph nodes in your
body to stop draining fluid correctly so
it pulls up and makes your body parts
swell to a massive size until you look
like an elephant and of course there's
the nasty disease known more commonly as
the bone growth disease or the bone
prison syndrome when most people's
muscle cells die they get a nasty bruise
but no lasting damage but for people
with this rare genetic mutation dead
muscle cells ossify they turn into bone
and muscle cells die slowly anyway even
if they're not damaged in any way over
the years sufferers have had their body
gradually turn into solid bone all
strange and terrifying aren't they but
none of them are anomalies surprising as
it may seem they're all perfectly real
diseases documented by modern science
you can even search them up and see
evidence if you don't believe us but it
begs the question if these seemingly
logic defying and impossible diseases
are just the ones known by modern
science then what kind of diseases break
our understanding of science physics
biology and chemistry so much that they
need to be categorized as anomalous and
of course contain by the foundation we
have a few examples the most notable of
which is
scp-008 the fabled Zombie Plague exactly
what it sounds like on the tin but today
we're going to be looking at something
else entirely one of the many anomalous
biohazards that the foundation keeps in
Cold Storage deep below the surface of
the Earth to ensure that they're never
to infect another human being again but
this one is a little unique when we talk
about dangerous diseases we always
consider the outcome the most danger a
disease could possibly pose to be deaf
however our topic for the day doesn't do
that frankly death might be preferable
to what it does to you
scp-2376 has a nickname around the
foundation's medical department they
call it the Scarecrow virus that name
alone raises a lot of questions usually
diseases are named scientifically or
according to the symptoms they give to
anyone unlucky enough to be infected by
them but scarecrows aren't dangerous
they're not even alive the simple little
straw effigy issues that farmers stick
in their corn and wheat Fields so that
crows don't pick their crops clean
before they can be harvested what do
scarecrows have to do with a biological
threat that the foundation has decided
is dangerous and anomalous enough that
it must be contained at least the wider
World learn about it well I suppose the
only way to find out is by reading its
documentation which is honestly quite
sparse it's not the massive multi-page
goliaths that many entries can turn into
it's short it's simple and perhaps it's
better that way this is one of those
cases where the more details you get the
more disturbing the anomaly is but let's
get into it
scp-2376's object class is Euclid which
is at least a good first sign it means
that it's not too hard to contain which
in the context of a disease means that
it's not amazingly communicative or
contagious that's good all things
considered
scp-008 and scp-610 by contrast are
incredibly communicative of and that's
part of why they can be so hard for the
foundation to contain the special
containment procedures for scp-2376 are
a little odd in fact they barely
reference
scp-2376 itself instead they mostly
refer to
scp-2376-1 instances and how to care for
them feed them communicate with them and
so on and so forth they go into detail
that
scp-2376-1 instances can't be fed
normally but by using an automated
feeding system to limit human exposure
to them but they still need meticulous
care they have to be examined at least
once every eight hours by Foundation
medical staff and the discomfort that
comes as a result of their infections is
to be alleviated as much as possible
while precise they're not exactly
surprising we know it's a disease so it
makes sense that these
scp-2376-1 instances are the victims of
the disease and as they're severely ill
they need to be fed and examined without
making their condition whatever it is
even worse or spreading it to staff but
they go on and they get stranger
scp-2376-1 instances can actually be
informed or made aware of the fact that
the diseases they're suffering from
scp-2376 is anomalous for some reason
they cannot be told about the anomalous
properties of it a text-based
communicator for the disabled kind of
like the computer voice system used by
Stephen Hawking has to be used to
communicate with the instances but
Personnel can't just wait for them to
type something out they have to close
and reopen their eyes every five minutes
to see if they've typed anything out for
some reason either victims of scp-2376
can't move when they're being looked at
like the infamous SCP-173 or that people
can't sense that victims have moved
until they close and reopen their eyes
either way very anomalous not to mention
the fact that they won't or can't speak
the next line is a very hard very firm
rule though not just a directive for
care under absolutely no circumstances
or patience to be removed from their
rooms or disposed of no removing from
rooms makes sense you don't want the
disease to spread and cross-contaminate
with the various other anomalies the
foundation site has in its Halls who
knows what kind of superbug you might
wind up with but disposal is a different
matter the foundation isn't allowed to
get rid of victims of this disease that
seems obvious the foundation doesn't
kill people if at all avoidable clearly
something else is at play here the next
line gives a hint Personnel have to
follow any instructions given to them
while treating instances and have to be
regularly reminded that they're treating
a human being whatever this disease does
to people it causes others to not
recognize them as human and may
accidentally dispose of them all the
instances slash victims as well as
samples of the disease itself are
located at site-234 and MTF beta 7 the
mass Hatters are to regularly
investigate hospitals in the area with
prior infection for repeat instances
beta 7 is a mobile task force trained
and equipped specifically to deal with
contagious or infectious anomalies a
cross between soldiers and doctors
scp-2376 is a substrain of the real
world tetanus virus which is often
called lockjaw most people get a tetanus
shot in childhood that protects them
from the disease with regular booster
shots so they never have to suffer
through the grisly infection that's
often found on rusty metal lockjaw is
called that because the bacteria infects
your muscles and makes them violently
spasm locking your jaw muscles into a
closed position there's no cure and
about 10 percent of cases are fatal but
the Scarecrow virus is different while
tetanus is found on Rusty Nails
scp-2376 is zoonotic it's communicated
and carried by animals specifically the
common crow that sheds some light on the
name while it's carried by crows it's
transmissible to humans too as we
guessed the unfortunate victims are
designated
scp-2376-1 instances by the foundation
scp-2376's infection of humans consists
of two distinct stages stage one and
stage two stage one is of course first
and at first seems mild could last
between one and four weeks and as all
the symptoms of the regular tetanus
virus like a fever spasms and loss of
Mobility but with some extra ones people
also develop a reddish rash across their
body a cough and vertigo they become
afraid of heights that would be strange
enough but it also affects the senses
victims who haven't progressed to stage
two yet complain about always smelling
the odor of straw corn and other
materials you'd find on a farm even when
they're nowhere near any Farm they say
that everything they touch has a strange
sort of film or texture on it like rough
burlap the kind that you'd find a bag of
potatoes to be made of this is all
certainly strange but it's not something
that you'd think must be contained by
the foundation just an odd variant of
the tetanus virus but stage 2 is when
things really get complicated the
anomalous properties of the disease
become readily apparent after the victim
progresses to stage two they stop being
perceived as human anyone who looks at
them only sees a regular unmoving
inanimate scarecrow it's not that they
become a scarecrow either just that
people can no longer perceive them as
anything but which is arguably worse
observers don't realize that the person
they were looking at just a moment ago
is suddenly gone or has been replaced by
a scarecrow to them everything seems
normal they don't realize or question
that anything's wrong in fact they can't
even perceive any noises in
scp-2376-1 instance makes like yelling
or calling for help that's why they have
to use the text communication but why
the five-minute delay because people
can't perceive any motion by scp-2376
6-1 instances either at least not while
looking at them if one runs across the
room right in front of an observer they
won't realize it and we'll see the
Scarecrow still sitting where it started
but if they look away by turning around
or closing their eyes before making
visual contact with it again the
Scarecrow will be in the position where
the
scp-2376-1 instance stopped moving the
disease doesn't just affect the person
who has it once stage 2 sets in it
affects people who don't have it and
have no exposure to it besides looking
at a victim that's why it's anomalous it
manages to change how people's nervous
systems and senses act while never even
infecting them
scp-2376 can't infect microphones or
motion detectors either though any
sounds made will still be picked up in a
sound recording and anyone tripping a
motion detector alarm will have its
sound immediately that makes containment
a little easier now that the foundation
can depend on at least physics and sound
but then you'd think a picture or
photograph of an
scp-2376-1 instance would look like a
normal person right albeit bedridden
with a rash and spasming but a human
being you'd be wrong and same about
videos visual media just renders the
victims as what they appear to the naked
eye a regular harmless scarecrow there
is one way to stop the effect that
scp-2376 has on perceiving its victims
but it's not pretty when a victim dies
of the infection they can be perceived
as a human again though of course by
then it is far too late thankfully being
infected by scp-2376 isn't a death
sentence the parts and symptoms of the
disease are shared with regular tetanus
can be alleviated with the same
treatments and remedies though they
can't be fully cured and even if all the
other symptoms go away the largest and
most anomalous aspect the effect on
others perceptions stays as if testing
so far there's no way to get rid of that
aspect of the disease except accept of
course death and the foundation has
performed extensive testing with samples
of scp-2376 murine models they infected
Lab Rats with the disease to see if the
reaction was the same as humans and how
it compared to Lab Rats with tetanus the
answer was extremely similar just like
tetanus if an
scp-2376-1 instance was pregnant when
they were infected the disease would
easily transfer to the fetus and give
the baby the Scarecrow virus from birth
and rats that went to Stage 2 also were
perceived as scarecrows tiny little
straw stuffed scarecrows shaped like
mice and stuffed with Denim and straw
but unlike humans rats and mice eat
straw which is exactly what the
non-infected rats began to do to the
infected ones they were unable to
perceive the rat's cries or thrashing
and cannibalized it but scp-2376 and
tetanus are bacterial infections by
eating the infected Rats the other rats
also became infected showing the
Disturbed foundations researchers how
this disease managed to spread unnoticed
protocols were immediately implemented
to make sure rats and mice couldn't get
into the containment chambers of
scp-2376-1 instances plus they try to
start eating them and spread the disease
like wildfire through site-234 until the
medical researchers can get a better
understanding of what exactly
scp-2376 is and how it affects other
mammals besides crows people and mice
testing is ordered to continue and
several other researchers have noted how
similar the effects of the virus are to
other anomalies such as
scp-2316 a pathogen that causes the
entire body to lock up and stop doing
everything and scp-2218 a number of
teleporting intelligence scarecrows
maybe
scp-2376 is the result of these two
anomalies coming into contact and
interacting as some of the researchers
are investigating or maybe it's much
more nefarious perhaps these anomalies
share a common synthetic origin like
someone trying to create an anomalous
biological weapon or maybe it really is
just a coincidence
scp-2376 was first encountered by the
foundation in the exact place anyone
would expect to find straw and
scarecrows the wide vast cornfields of
Iowa in the United States but they
didn't find them in a field of wheat or
in a barn they found them where you'd
expect to find disease victims a
hospital more specifically Foundation
agents found a number of corpses stuffed
into the garbage disposal units of the
hospital of a small Iowa town the nurses
and janitors at the hospital had no idea
what happened they said that some
teenagers had broken in during the night
and dressed a number of scarecrows and
scrubs before leaving them in the wards
as a prank the staff in the morning had
found and disposed of them in the trash
knowing what we know about
scp-2376 the actual story is much more
tragic somehow the infection had
probably gotten into a human at the
hospital and the doctors be began
treating it the same as they would
tetanus the doctors and nurses had also
got infected and quickly entered into
stage two while at work but remember
victims stop being perceived as
scarecrows when they die which means
that when Hospital staff threw them into
the trash they were still alive if you
can call that alive but their thrashing
and yelling couldn't be perceived by the
others once they went into the disposal
units they quickly deteriorated and died
a deeply tragic situation all around but
how did
scp-2376 get to the hospital where did
it even come from Foundation agents have
a pretty solid Theory they scoured the
local town for any strange events
incidents or rumors about scarecrows and
found something much bigger than what
they were expecting a week before the
corpses in the hospital were discovered
a man in the next town over had died or
more accurately he had been killed his
wife called 9-1-1 incoherent and sobbing
and explained to the operator that she
found a spare scarecrow on the garage a
week before and I nailed it up outside
of the house on a post after three days
she had walked outside and found instead
of the Scarecrow the body of her husband
at which point she broke down and called
9-1-1 the woman was tried for murder but
acquitted on an insanity plea based on
her claims of her husband having turned
into a scarecrow the man's corpse was
sent to the morgue at the hospital for
an autopsy which is probably how the
infection spread to the other hospital
staff but not before the autopsy was
completed and a report filed indicating
cause of death dehydration from being
out in the hot sun for three days
Foundation staff quickly moved in and
quarantined the body confirmed the
presence of
scp-2376 in the blood and the wife
confirmed her husband had symptoms
similar to tetanus a few weeks ago as
for how the infection got into the man
that remains a mystery the outbreak was
considered contained by the foundation
and since then there have been only
cases here and there throughout the
American and Midwest until now an
addendum to the file indicates that the
foundation has located and identified a
new strain of
scp-2376 the key difference being the
carrier and the effect rather than crows
it is transmitted by pigeons and its
origin point is in the highly Urban
location in Illinois more likely than
not it's in the third largest city in
the United States Chicago and the second
difference is that instead of scarecrows
the infected are perceived as inanimate
mannequins the kind you'd see in any
clothing or department store based off
the vastly increased risk for the
epidemic the foundation's medical
Department have requested that
scp-2376 be reclassified to ketter
scp-2376 goes to show how even the
diseases we don't know exist can be
dangerous in more ways than just
threatening our lives so next time you
see a crow Scavenging for food in your
front lawn maybe think twice about
getting too close to scare it away you
might just wind end up on a pole in the
same front yard scaring crows away in
your new straw-stuffed overalls forever
there are many things in this world that
we do not and perhaps cannot understand
the SCP Foundation dedicates itself to
researching and containing these things
but even they occasionally encounter
something that defies any kind of true
understanding the unknown is terrifying
to the average person but for an
organization that specializes in knowing
the unknowable a mystery that refuses to
be understood can be downright
nightmarish a foundation Expedition team
lost contact with their command while on
a mission in the northern Ural Mountains
of Russia after six hours of Silence
radio contact was re-established though
video feed continued to be disabled a
loan agent Dr fellenstein called out
desperately over the radio waves begging
for someone anyone to answer him command
responded requesting a status update on
the rest of his through at first they
were met only with the wet Hollow sound
of felonstein weeping finally he
explained that they were all dead and
that he was the only man left standing
something hot to him he said a fellow
agent Myers it was long slippery I saw a
grown man pulled into a tiny hole he
began to hyperventilate his descriptions
becoming less and less coherent command
offered to send reinforcements to
collect the Survivor but he begged them
not to it was beyond saving at this
point describing himself as nothing but
a Walking Corpse after slipping into a
crevice Valenstein had broken his ankle
and torn a hole in his hazmat suit
command honored his insistence that no
reinforcements be sent in but encouraged
him to try and pull himself back to the
surface and retrieve additional data
even if he was doomed he could still
provide valuable information on the
threat he encountered while felonstein
attempted to free himself from the
crevice He Slipped deeper into the crack
in the ground pushing through his fear
of being crushed to death he tried again
fighting against the burning of the
toxic air in his lungs and the straining
of his muscles he finally pulled himself
to Freedom then he took in his
surroundings he was at the edge of a
Chasm so deep he could not see the
bottom he posited that he was somewhere
underneath or inside of a mountain there
was a putrid smell in the air burning
his eyes his skin everything command
told him to remain calm still hoping for
the possibility of a rescue meanwhile on
their end hostile forces were closing in
and forcing them to evacuate they asked
Valenstein to continue describing his
surroundings so that his account might
be recorded for the archives they would
attempt to come back with reinforcements
when it was safe for them to do so as
felenstein made it deeper into the chasm
he was engulfed in a thick yellow fog
through the haze he could make out
thousands of eggs and piles of meat
being devoured by small creatures with
the bodies of grubs and the faces of
human infants the creatures did not
respond to his presence either unaware
of him or too consumed with their
feeding to care as he passed the
creatures he spotted a massive black
Temple with architecture like nothing he
had seen before all polished and sharp
with angles that hurt his eyes to look
at as he stopped to take a better look
he realized he was still moving somehow
without moving his feet he was being
dragged by something tendrils wrapped
around his legs and pulling him along
against his will leaving a trail of his
blood behind as he was dragged dozens of
what seemed like humans watched him the
final words recorded on the audio
transcript were the most troubling of
all fallenstein saw what he described as
an angel with a thousand Wings the angel
pulled him into her Embrace clutching
him to her breast and the connection was
lost Dr fellenstein was never seen again
his colleague's bodies were never
recovered the entire team of men was
lost forever inside the incomprehensible
hell hole known as
scp-2133
scp-2133 is an unnamed Village in the
northern Ural Mountains in Eastern
Europe with an estimated popular
relation of around 50 people the village
is considered dangerous to enter without
proper Hazmat gear due to the presence
of a wide variety of microbial pathogens
within its limits including those which
cause leprosy mnemonic septemic and
bubonic plagues typhoid fever influenza
cholera and smallpox a veritable
hypochondriac's worst nightmare in spite
of this cocktail diseases in which they
live the residents of 2133 seem to be
resistant to the negative effects of
infection of course they experience
physical symptoms to the point of
visible disfigurement or disability but
they do not die at a rate consistent
with the sheer volume of deadly
pathogens present in their town the
people of scp-2133 do not leave it the
foundation cannot fully determine
whether they cannot leave or simply
choose not to but whatever the case may
be they stay within the limits of their
Village their relative resistance to
disease small population and refusal to
leave the boundaries of their Village
are all unusual but that is far from the
most most unusual thing about the
population of
scp-2133 the people of the village age
and die yes but they do not stay dead
they engage in what can only be
described as some kind of reincarnation
when a resident of the village dies they
are placed in the field where they
quickly Decay on the night of the First
new moon a newborn infant is pulled from
the soil where the decaying body once
lay the reborn version of each person
looks like their previous self and
Carries all of the memories they had in
their previous life the foundation
performed extensive soil tests on the
field where this curious rebirth takes
place and found that the soil bear
contains high levels of embryonic fluid
beyond the presence of this fluid in the
earth it is unknown how exactly this
reincarnation process works the
residents of the village known as
scp-2133-1 speak an old Russian dialect
and occasionally agree to be interviewed
by Foundation staff fluent in the style
act though they will sit for interview
views and chat with Foundation Personnel
they are secretive about their lives
their history and the culture of their
little village the first resident to be
successfully interviewed was an elderly
man named aristica who was missing his
left arm and had necrosis on most of his
visible skin the interview was conducted
by Dr Judith Lowe one of the head
researchers on the case she asked the
man how far back he was able to remember
and he recounted a time of czars and
cons when Dr Lowe pressed the man about
the rebirth that his people practice he
responded that it was the Church of the
red Harvest we serve until the end that
is the terms of our agreement Dr Lowe
asked him why he and the rest of his
people would continue to live their
lives this way when it caused them such
obvious suffering he explained simply
there is no choice the land calls we
answer she continued to push the issue
inquiring about how this all began so
many years ago he explained that a
priestess came to the valley many many
lifetimes ago she offered the people
Paradise in exchange for their servitude
however as the years passed the people
became more and more exhausted they
feared they had failed somehow and were
being punished aristikoff became visibly
upset at this point in the interview but
continued to insist the Church of the
red Harvest is truth there is no other
the second interview was conducted Again
by Dr Judith Lowe who spoke with Anya a
young girl who appeared to be between
the ages of six and eight Lo greeted the
girl and attempted to ask her the first
question but Anya simply said you don't
belong here leave Lo brushed this off
and offered the girl medical assistance
but was rebuffed again you are not of
the Covenant you will never understand
Dr Lowe asked Anya to elaborate on the
nature of this Covenant and her
explanation was similar to that of the
previous interviewee there was an
agreement made a long time ago and now
the people of the village would serve
until the end of time again she and
insisted that the foundation should
leave and did not belong in the town
finally irritated with the questions
Anya had only this to say about the
church the church was here long before
the village a church of stone beneath
the Earth it is sacred a church of wood
was built atop it for the hearsay of the
Cross before we embrace the true Faith
the karcissist Alka will Enlighten you
you are only alive because she has
chosen to let you live hearing the word
karsus probably gives you some
indication as to what's really going on
here if the disease corruption and
mutation of the flesh didn't give you
enough of a clue this horror is sarcic
through and through Dr Lowe's final
question was a seemingly easy one does
the village have a name as soon as the
words left Dr Low's lips Anya began to
vomit up a thick black substance ending
the interview instances of
scp-2133-1 are largely apathetic towards
Foundation agents unless they get in the
way of their routine the agents are
allowed to go inside any of the
buildings in the village with one
notable exception the Church of the red
Harvest any attempts to learn more about
the church or enter its walls are met
with refusal to explain or in some cases
outright hostility though the villagers
are largely peaceful toward the
foundation they are not the only entity
living in scp-2133 throughout the
village there are instances of something
known as
scp-2133-2 these organic structures
which have the appearance of dark red
tentacles display overt hostility
towards Outsiders and will attack any
that get too close they are especially
aggressive to any Outsiders that attempt
to enter the church tissue samples were
taken from the tentacles for observation
and they were found horrifyingly enough
to genetically resemble tissue samples
from humans after the interview with
Anya the foundation research team
determined that entering the church was
of the utmost importance mobile task
force beta 7 was dispatched for this
mission and after the residents of the
Town were restrained a team of 12
operatives was sent in they were armed
with radios video recorders hazmat suits
and air tanks as they attempted to enter
the church the tentacles attacked but
were subdued with flamethrowers
apparently like most living things they
are not immune to fire inside the church
the research team found small Idols
crafted from bone and leather and a few
others made from tumors hanging from
Iron hooks on the ceiling at the
building center was an entrance to a
system of caves and caverns Beneath The
Village stretching Beyond its borders
into the mountains several previously
unseen organisms designated only as
scp-2133-3 were discovered inside one
was terminated and taken back to the
foundation for an autopsy the creature
was humanoid in nature with swollen
organs and flesh and an overgrowth of
bone and fatty tissue after the autopsy
the team of operatives refreshed their
air tanks and headed back into the
village to continue their research about
about 50 minutes into their expedition
all contact was lost out of nowhere six
hours later Dr felenstein would make his
Infamous radio contact and the nightmare
would unfold from there currently
scp-2133 is easily contained a secure
perimeter is maintained at the 10
kilometer radius around the town
preventing any civilians from making
their way inside there are guards
positioned along the perimeter under the
guise of a Russian military base in
spite of the horrifying nature of
scp-2133 the villagers do not seem to
pose an immediate threat to anyone they
simply want to be left alone to till the
fields and attend their Church in an
endless cycle of winters and Summers as
they wait for the end to come as they
hope that finally their agreement will
be honored and that they will find peace
across all cultures and people humans
have always had one enduring question
what happens to us after we die as soon
as we figured out what death is isn't
that all humans die excluding some very
special anomalies we started wondering
what comes next is there some kind of
heaven or hell are we judged based on
our deeds in this life or is it just
Purgatory for all eternity assuming of
course that there's anything at all
maybe it's just nothingness who knows
some people who have had near-death
experiences like being hit by a truck or
having their heart stopped report going
into the Afterlife but almost all of
these claims were retracted or debunked
and of course there's the famous white
light on the other side of the tunnel
that people say precedes death the human
fascination with death extends beyond
that too mythologies all have their own
interpretations of what happens after
the physical body stops functioning the
ancient Greeks believed in Hades a realm
ruled by the god of the same name where
the souls of the Dead would go to be
separated into those who were good in
life and those who were bad the good
would Feast for eternity in Elysium
while the bad woods suffer horrible and
poetic punishments depending on what
they did the ancient Egyptians also
believed in an underworld of the dead
though theirs was different from their
Greek cousin they believed in the dwath
which was pretty similar to Egypt itself
it had Plains lakes rivers deserts dead
Souls would travel down the Nile River
To Face judgment and either be rewarded
or obliterated many Egyptian gods and
goddesses were also said to reside in
the dwap and some cultures don't believe
in an afterlife at all at least not how
most do Tibetan Buddhists believe in a
cycle of reincarnation when someone dies
their souls were born in the body of a
new living thing one can be reincarnated
as another human a plant an animal or
even an insect what you're reincarnated
into depends on your deeds in your past
life interacting with other
reincarnations and you can only escape
the cycle of death and reincarnation by
reaching spiritual enlightenment Nirvana
needless to say many call cultures have
their unique interpretation of what
happens to the soul and the spirit after
your body dies but there's no proof or
way to confirm anything so it's all
confined to the realm of belief there's
no way to reach into the Afterlife and
speak to someone to find out what it's
like or is there well that definitely
sounds like an anomaly to me doesn't it
but the SCP Foundation doesn't just have
one anomaly related to what happens
after you die some of you may have seen
our video on scp-2718 what happens after
death it's an anomaly very very few
people know about the long and short of
it is that scp-2718 is a Cognito Hazard
once you learn about it it infects you
and when someone infected with it dies
their mind and soul stay intact after
they die but they can't move their body
so they're cursed into staying perfectly
conscious and aware of every nerve and
sensation in the body even as they're
buried and decomposed over decades
without being able to do anything about
it horrible people isn't it totally and
that's why you should watch it
immediately after you finish this video
luckily the scp-2718 file is safely
quarantined and buried in the database
it can't be excised completely but
making it so that only a handful of
people ever have a chance of stumbling
upon it is the best the foundation can
do to contain this anomaly as for those
people who do well what can you do for a
very very long time the o5 council
thought that scp-2718 was the definitive
answer to the question of what happens
after death but another anomaly
discovered several years later
overturned that answer
scp-2922 notes from the under
scp-2922 isn't anywhere near as heavily
classified as
scp-2718 so we can read it safely
without worrying about infecting
ourselves which is pretty good
considering what it can do but let's get
into it
scp-2922 is a euclid-class anomaly and
consists of three parts
scp-2922-a which is contained under high
security at area 2922 a small facility
built especially to contain it 24 hours
a day seven days a week one staff member
from Project corbinik has to be in its
containment chamber to answer any calls
that might come from it in case you
weren't aware corbaneck is the name of
the castle where Legends say the Holy
Grail is kept and was discovered by King
Arthur maybe
scp-2922-a is connected to it
scp-2922-c also needs to be researched
by
scp-2922-b due to its importance to
Foundation operations
scp-2922-b seems to be some kind of
person in that case but what does any of
this mean you see scp-2922 is a method
of communication between a human brain
and a telephone more specifically it's a
kind of concept but the foundation would
call a memetic Cognito Hazard those are
big words but think of them as Forbidden
Knowledge once you learn them they
affect how you think and you're able to
act differently because of them you do
this in real life too when you study
something in a textbook you're suddenly
able to use knowledge you didn't have
before the only difference is
scp-2922 allows you to do something
anomalous with it namely when a subject
is implanted with scp-2922 in a
secretive procedure they can use their
mind to call a phone number a specific
phone number has to be chosen but it can
be any number you want imagine being
able to dial up your friends or family
without using a phone and imagine your
phone ringing only to learn it's someone
talking from their mind Nifty but this
doesn't seem terribly dangerous right
the foundation isn't quite sure how it
works after performing research
involving scp-2922 infected subjects
calling phone numbers they've detected
that no radio waves or communication
signals are involved which is part of
why it is an anomaly but how would
something like this be created well as
scp-2922 was created years before the
foundation ever heard of it by a small
software development company they were
trying to create an app that would allow
you to send messages to people and
somehow accidentally created an app that
was telepathic it could send messages
from the mind when they realized what
they'd created they got scared and
Abandoned and buried the project
destroying all their copies of the app
well almost all the foundation heard
about the project several years later
and managed to locate a single remaining
copy of the scp-2922 program from the
depths of the company's archives even
though it's an app it can be used to
call landline phones too which is
exactly what the foundation did after a
few more months of research and
experimentation they confirmed that the
app wasn't using the electric signals of
the brain like the company had thought
it was actual real telepathy they even
managed to create an scp-2922 connection
between a researcher and an office
telephone that's what the sub-anomolies
are
scp-2922-a is a simple landline phone
the kind you'd see in a receptionist
desk or in someone's office space it's
the designation number that
scp-2922-b can call into
scp-2922-b is of course the human
element of scp-2922 but the foundation
only had one chance at success at this
experiment because of the singular copy
of the app so instead of choosing a
random d-class who couldn't be trusted
or might ruin the test they had one
researcher volunteer to be host to
scp-2922 Dr Janet Spiegel a woman who
had been with the foundation's research
division for over a decade she was
approved and implanted with
scp-2922 but what is
scp-2922-c well that's Dr Spiegel's
current location as of November 11 2014.
the foundation believes she's not on
this Earth anymore or even in this
reality but located in an extra
dimensional location
you see only two months after Dr Spiegel
was implanted with scp-2922 tragedy
struck while driving to work her car was
rammed by a drunk driver killing her
instantly but only two hours later the
scp-2922-a phone began to ring the
researcher picked up the phone first
answering that the caller had the wrong
number but was interrupted by Dr Spiegel
thanking God someone had picked up the
doctor thought it was a prank call but
Dr Spiegel quickly rattled off her name
email password and social security
number after her credentials were
verified the researchers were
incredulous they had just heard that her
car had been in an accident and that she
had died Dr Spiegel confirmed that the
only thing she could remember was
driving through snow and rain and seeing
a bright light coming toward her and
then she woke up in the middle of a wide
flat desert then it hit her that she
really was truly dead and wouldn't be
coming back before promising to call
back in a few minutes she explained she
needed time to process the reality of
her situation to the sympathetic
co-workers meanwhile the overseer
Council approved project corbanek a
foundation operation to use Dr Spiegel
as
scp-2922-b to explore and catalog what
scp-2922-c was if she really was dead
then that would mean the strange desert
she was in was the afterlife the
research team was informed of their new
assignment and the next day they began
to call in to Dr Spiegel at first they
just wanted to figure out the landscape
of the strange Dimension during the
first call they interviewed Dr Spiegel
on her surroundings she was still in the
large white desert and the sky was a
dark sea green with black clouds and no
stars but the most obvious features were
three large white moons floating in the
sky in place of the sun it was cold
about 10 degrees Celsius cold enough to
make her shiver but no wind anywhere she
couldn't see any other signs of life no
animals no people no wind no sound at
all it was completely silent except for
her breathing she still had her body
though when asked about how she felt she
couldn't feel pain hunger or even a need
to do anything but before they could
continue she asked if she could speak to
her husband the researchers told her
they'd need to talk to the o5 council
about it and that they tried to convince
them Dr Spiegel missed her husband and
they were sure he felt the same about
his wife then she offered a plan she'd
walk infinitely in One Direction until
she saw something other than desert then
she'd call them again the researchers
agreed and Dr Spiegel hung up the phone
five whole days after that call the
phone rang again the researchers picked
it up only to hear scp-2922 out of
breath and panting when asked what
happened she started to explain she had
been traveling through the desert for
five days though this place had no day
night cycle and she hadn't felt tired or
hungry then she encountered a mountain
range and began to approach its base
when she saw a life form but it wasn't
human it walked on two feet and looked
like a mammal but that was it it was
some kind of gigantic primate like a
massive gorilla it easily dwarfed the
mountains she saw and had to be at least
two kilometers tall she had felt it
before she had seen it huge slow
footsteps shaking the ground then sod
exit the mountain range she saw it had
matted black fur and two huge glowing
white eyes with no mouth but then it
stepped on her not aggressively just out
of curiosity it seemed to be
investigating her and seeing how much
force she could withstand she was
crushed flat of course but only a few
seconds later her body put itself back
together and she was back to normal then
it lost interest and went off into the
desert she had just come from the
researchers were incredulous at this
seeming confirmation that
scp-2922-c was the afterlife but they
were interrupted by Dr Spiegel saying
that she could see people making
campfires in the valley ahead hun
hundreds of them huddled up in some
buried halfway into the ground the
researchers guessed they were trying to
escape their situation and Dr Spiegel
worried aloud that she'd wind up like
them then she made another request
citing the service she had been
competently performing with full loyalty
that she be allowed to speak to her
husband but the o5s had already decided
that she would only be authorized to
speak with other project corbinet
Personnel she asked the foundation to
hire him but with an art history degree
he wouldn't be of use to the foundation
Beyond this one anomaly angrily she
swore and hung up the phone next time
they heard from her the call was brief
and I see Dr Spiegel was clearly still
angry over being denied the right to
speak to her husband but claimed she had
good news a wagon being driven by a
skeletal horse and a tall man in a white
robe had come to the human Camp he
informed them that they were being taken
to a place called The Elysian Fields
remember Elysium the Greek afterlife
from earlier Dr Spiegel did and believed
that the man was taking them to a sort
of paradise the researchers remarked
that she didn't seem very happy but she
quickly hung up the phone after that
strange exchange
scp-2922 didn't ring for a very long
time no further Transmissions came in
for seven months all attempts to phone
Dr Spiegel instead rang and rang but
were never picked up project corbinik
was put on hold until one day a
voicemail came to
scp-2922-a the voicemail was recorded by
Dr Spiegel but was different in tone
from the other calls it seemed angry she
explained that she had been keeping an
eye on the foundation's efforts to track
her down using the fact that she had
gained the favor of some kind of
powerful Godlike entity she told the
foundation about the possibility of an
Elysium afterlife a paradise and then
knew that they'd want more she had lied
about the Grim Reaper but everything
else had been entirely true but what
happened after she visited the human
Camp was in her words far too
complicated to explain but she would be
more than happy to answer the
foundation's questions of what happens
after you die for a small price if the
o5 council let her speak to her husband
she'd tell them everything but if they
weren't willing to accept one civilian
then she'd know and would never tell
them the real answer she signed off
ending the voicemail the researchers
were shocked at this sudden betrayal and
forward the request up the ladder but by
the time the o5 council began
deliberating on whether to involve her
husband in
scp-2922 something else happened
Foundation researchers tracked another
voicemail coming from the same kind of
anomaly except it was going to Herman
Spiegel's house Dr Spiegel's widowed
husband figuring that she was trying to
contact her husband mobile task force
psy8 the silencers raided his home but
as soon as they threw open the door and
moved in Mr Spiegel threw the phone
towards the wall to destroy it and was
shot by the soldiers the phone however
was unharmed and still had one voicemail
on it that the foundation was able to
extract the voicemail was from
scp-2922-b Janet Spiegel talking to her
husband At first she was assuring him
that he wasn't insane and that he really
was hearing his wife from Beyond the
Grave then told him to listen carefully
while she explained the same Godlike
entity she had befriended had worked
some magic to allow her to contact a
phone besides
scp-2922-a one time she told him that a
foundation task force was headed to his
house and would be there within 10
minutes not just any task force Psy 8 a
squad dedicated to Black Ops executions
there wasn't time to run he would die
but she reassured him that all wasn't
loss even though the situation must be
terrifying she knew he was an atheist
but she was proof that there was an
afterlife and not just one millions of
afterlives and the one she was in was
preferable to most of the others most
importantly her husband could join her
he already knew how to get it to the
afterlife even if he didn't remember
he'd figure it out on the way her
husband listened to her instructions
with wrapped attention she advised him
on the path he should take once he got
to the desert he should follow the moon
on the left until he reached the valley
where the Striders the massive primates
dwelled there he should ask one of the
trees where she had gone and follow that
path she also advised him not to do
anything to anger anyone let the
Striders kill him it's their way of
saying hello he'd regenerate with no
harm done but there were Fates worse
than death that he should avoid at all
costs getting sent back for one but
before she could finish her advice both
of them realized that the MTF were at
his door hardly telling him to delete
the voicemail so the foundation wouldn't
find out she assured him that she had
help from her Godlike friend and that
she fully believed in him and that he
should never give up she told him she
loved him Forever by shooting Mr Spiegel
the MTF had inadvertently sent him to
scp-2922-c along with his wife but the
foundation wasn't done yet
scp-2922 had let them set up operation
Galahad a project to Saint train
Foundation operatives into the Afterlife
to try and apprehend Janet Spiegel
before she could bring down the
foundation operation Galahad has plenty
more stories where that came from but
we'll cover those a different day gather
round boys and girls and those who are
young at heart we've talked a lot before
about the wacky occasionally wonderful
but always weird creations of the
mysterious toy maker Dr wondertainment
and today we're going to do it again
it's time to crack open the SCP
foundation's toy chest and see what we
can find inside Dr wondertainment's
inventions have been attracting the
attention of the foundation for quite
some time and with good reason whoever
or whatever the Whimsical talented
doctor is there's no one else out there
producing quite as many anomalous
objects and marketing them to children
as playthings these aren't the toys
you'll find in your neighborhood store
or on someone's Amazon wishlist there's
scp-445 the Super Paper that comes alive
in the form of whatever you folded into
scp-1508 or Mikey the chore buddy a
living cardboard robot designed to help
kids with their chores there are the
adorable yet destructive fire-breathing
dragon snails or scp-111 or SC
19958 General beep who teaches kids
about military history and combat and
helps them build real working toy
weapons I could keep talking through the
proverbial Toy Factory but we'd be here
all day maybe Dr wondertainment's most
anomalous trait is how productive he
manages to be I can barely send a single
email without three cups of coffee but
enough about me one of the most
well-known Dr wondertainment Creations
is the little misters line a series of
humanoid Playmates with a variety of
different traits we've covered the
little misters here on SCP explained
before but let's do a quick refresh just
in case there's Mr chameleon Mr headless
Mr laugh Mr forgetful Mr shapey Mr soap
Mr Hungry Mr brass Mr hot Mr life and Mr
death Mr Fish Mr Moon Mr red Mr Money Mr
lost Mr lie Mr mad Mr scary and Mr
Stripes each of these little misters
from the top hat wearing fish to the man
who can't remember a thing they're each
special in their own way but wait a
minute looking at them all lined up like
that I can't help but feel like I'm
missing something it seems like a bit of
a boys club right and why let boys have
all the fun while it seems like Dr
wondertainment thought the very same
thing because he made a little Mister
Just For Girls enter Miss sweetie the
sweetest pinkest gal around at first
glance you might mistake Miss sweetie
for an ordinary woman aside from her
naturally pink hair and eyes no wig or
contact lenses here but like the rest of
her fellow misters Miss sweetie has more
to her than meets the eye So What Lies
Beneath that candy-coated sugary
exterior to crack open that hard candy
shell and get the truth inside we'll
have to look a few years back to when
Miss sweetie first caught the 10
attention of the foundation it all
started in a small unassuming Town
tucked away in a valley flanked on
either side by mountains and thick
forests it was a peaceful place if a bit
boring the worst thing anyone could
remember happening in years was a
cheating scandal at the yearly pie bake
off then ten-year-old Nina went missing
her family was terrified they called the
police right away but the authorities
insisted that it looked like a classic
case of a little girl running away from
home after all she had taken her
backpack her favorite toys some
sandwiches and bottles of water from the
fridge she would come back home soon
probably later that day and everyone
would be able to laugh about this by
tomorrow but tomorrow came and Nina
still didn't return home people began to
whisper the way folks in small towns
always talk behind each other's backs
was there some trouble at home Nina had
seen like such a happy girl so outgoing
leading her troop in Girl Scout cookies
every year and singing solos in the
school choir something must have been
wrong though otherwise where did she go
then others began to disappear Tommy
Bowers was last spotted walking home
from school he fell behind his friends
stopping to tie his shoe when they
noticed he was no longer with them and
went back he was gone then Mikey Paulson
vanished on a camping trip in the nearby
Forest his father left him alone for a
second in broad daylight just to gather
some firewood for later that evening and
when he called out to his son for help
carrying it there was no reply one boy
was catching toads in the creek behind
his house when he disappeared another
was seemingly snatched while walking his
dog the dog unharmed ran back home on
her own dragging her leash behind her as
she went it had started with Nina but
now no one could be certain if it would
stop the townspeople began to panic
wondering who would be next who was
taking their children and why as it
always does small communities in the
grips of Terror suspicion began to grow
neighbors turned on each other pointing
fingers at anyone who seemed the least
bit suspicious local police were baffled
by the sudden slew of apparent
kidnappings sure they had a few
potential suspects an elderly woman with
the local kids claiming that she was a
witch a school groundskeeper that just
had a generally weird vibe about him but
none of the leads ever went anywhere
there was no evidence found at any of
the scenes where there were Footprints
there were only one set the child's
leading off into the woods until they
could no longer be tracked tensions were
mounting and no one could trust anyone
anymore in a town where people had
always left their doors unlocked people
were boarding up their Windows pulling
their children out of school and keeping
them home at all hours of the day if
they didn't after all their child could
be the next one to vanish after a week
of nail biting tension and looking for
threats around every every corner the
town was treated to a shocking surprise
Nina came home casually as you please
her parents saw her come skipping down
the driveway a little dirty and clearly
exhausted but cheerful they embraced her
weeping and she hugged them tight asking
them to please stop crying we didn't
know where you were her mother sobbed
didn't know if you were okay or I'm fine
Nina insisted they let you go her father
asked what I just got hungry and I
missed you so I came back Nina explained
who took you her mother asked no one
took me I was visiting my friend Nina
laughed her parents stared at her in
shock what friend her father stammered
the pink lady in the woods Nina said
simply and then she rushed inside to
grab a snack and say hello to the family
cat police came by the house to speak
with Nina and after talking in circle
about her friend in the woods and
refusing to say that she was kidnapped
she agreed to show the officers where
where this lady in the woods was other
than her location all they could get out
of Nina was that the lady was pink she
could do magic and she had lots of
friends they had no way to know for
certain but they hoped that this
mysterious woman would lead them to the
missing boys so that same day a team of
police officers none of whom had ever
seen more action than a parking ticket
or a teenage Vandal spray painting a
wall set out to recover the kidnapped
children from the lady in the woods it
wasn't easy to navigate following the
directions of a child what exactly did
she mean by go past the rock shaped like
a butt or look out for those purple
flowers I like in spite of their
obstacles though they were able to get
their bearings they realized they were
getting close though close to what they
couldn't quite be sure when officer Rita
Flynn stepped on something that crunched
loudly beneath her boot what the she
lifted her shoe to find a piece of
bright blue hard candy broken beneath
the Soul Candy in the middle of the
woods as they searched the area around
them the rest of the officers found
pieces of the same candy in different
shapes and colors all strangely inviting
for candy that they found on the ground
they couldn't explain the significance
of the candy but they knew it meant they
were getting close they followed the
multicolored candy Trail like Hansel and
Gretel tracking their path through the
forest with crumbs of bread they could
hear footsteps up ahead coming from a
nearby clearing through the trees the
team of officers could make out a log
cabin that looked like it had been
abandoned for quite some time as they
drew closer to the cabin than the sounds
of activity inside several of the
officers suddenly froze in their tracks
They insisted to be allowed to turn back
to go home they couldn't explain why but
they knew they needed to leave that
something did not want them there
officer Flynn the only female officer in
the group scoffed at her colleagues she
urged them not to be cowards and to keep
moving there were children's lives at
stake this was no time to get cold feet
still tentative but feeling thoroughly
shamed the rest of the officers followed
Rita towards the cabin so far so good no
sign of the missing boys but no sign of
Foul Play yet either then behind her
Flynn heard officer Simon let out a
groan of pain she turned and saw him
doubled over clutching his stomach
before anyone could intervene his knees
buckled and he fell to the ground
suddenly unconscious Flynn ran to check
his pulse and it was steady but he
wouldn't wake up his breath gave off a
slightly sweet smell and she remembered
her great uncle and a trip he'd taken to
the hospital somehow officer Simon had
fallen into a diabetic coma right there
in the woods before she had time to
think too hard about it officer Paul
collapsed in the exact same way right
before her eyes all around her as they
attempted to approach the cabin Flynn's
fellow officers were dropped like flies
she turned back to the cabin and her eye
caught the shock of pink hair as a woman
stepped out she made eye contact with
Flynn who took note of her unusual Vivid
Pink eyes and she waved hi there what's
your name she called in a syrupy sweet
voice officer Flynn Drew her weapon
hands where I can see them the
pink-haired woman cocked her head in
confusion but complied no need to be so
mean she pouted it's just us girls but
that wasn't entirely true in the forest
behind the cabin officer Flynn could see
humanoid figures trudging through the
trees but they weren't human they were
shiny hard and brightly colored she
thought of the candy she had stepped on
earlier and her jaw dropped as the Candy
People approached her she began to
recognize their faces the missing boys
each and every one of them transformed
somehow into living hard candy holding
her weapon in one hand and keeping an
eye on the pink-haired woman and her
tiny candy Army all the while she pulled
out her radio and called in the
strangest report she had ever made no
one in the town not even the chief of
police had ever heard of anything like
this but fortunately the police chief
knew someone who did an old friend who
devoted her time to investigating cases
that were impossible to explain less
than 24 hours after officer Flynn made
her call the SCP Foundation was arriving
at the scene to collect the candy
children and the woman who had become
known as Miss sweetie officer Flynn's
report along with an in-depth study of
both the hard candy pieces and the hard
candy humanoids obtained from the crime
scene offered some insights into Miss
sweetie's abilities her presence
inherently repels men that come within
50 yards of her and any man that enters
her radius will feel an immense desire
to leave and go back in the opposite
direction if he is forced to continue
his approach then he will begin to feel
ill experience nausea shortness of
breath and severe stomach pain finally
he would fall into what resembles a
spontaneous diabetic coma the only way
for him to regain Consciousness is to be
brought back outside of the 50-yard
radius as for the hard candy Foundation
researchers gave one piece to a female
d-class and another piece to a male
d-class to test the effect it might have
on different genders when the woman ate
her piece she simply chewed swallowed
and looked at the attending researcher
and confusion as if to say what was that
it when the man ate his piece however
his body began to undergo a rapid
transformation his blood sugar levels
skyrocketed rendering him immobile
almost immediately over the next 12
hours his flesh bones musculature and
all other parts of his body began to
crystallize into hard candy when the
transformation was complete the new
entity attempted to free Miss sweetie
from her containment he was neutralized
using a flamethrower which melted the
sugar of his body down into sticky
puddle any person identifying as a male
who eats a piece of this hard candy will
experience a similar effect just as the
missing boys did in some very rare cases
the transformed party will turn into a
candy unicorn rather than a humanoid
creature but the cause of these special
cases is unknown after Miss sweetie was
brought into Foundation custody and
given her official designation of
scp-2396 specialized containment
procedures were put in place to keep her
in captivity she was placed in
provisional site 2396 and due to her
distaste for men and boys assigned a
research staff that consisted entirely
of women any men or masculine
identifying individuals located within a
six kilometer radius of the site were to
be temporarily detained and questioned
about any possible contact with
scp-2396 so every night in provisional
site 2396 was ladies night but it wasn't
much of a party researchers were
preoccup with finding a way to
neutralize
scp-2396's anomalous effects most
notably in spite of her containment
small pieces of assorted hard candy or
scp-2396-a would be spontaneously
generated within a six kilometer radius
of Miss sweetie any of these that were
spotted would be incinerated on site but
the mobile task force in charge of
supervising the area was having trouble
keeping up male civilians were slipping
through the cracks eating the candy and
transforming into candy humanoids or
instances of
scp-2396-b then storming the site and
attempting to free Miss sweetie from
captivity it was becoming untenable to
keep her contained the generation of
instances of
scp-2396-a was directly connected to her
regular consumption of sugar in all of
its forms which she requested as rations
the amount did not matter nor did the
form it took she merely required
something sweet once a day sometimes it
was a bowl of pure cane sugar sometimes
a cup of maple syrup on a staff member's
birthday they brought her a piece of
chocolate cake which she was especially
delighted by eventually they settled on
a single liter of glucose syrup once a
day hoping it could slow things down by
eliminating any Whimsy or variation from
the feedings every time without fail
more instances of the anomalous candy
would manifest soon after
scp-2396 ate her meal it was talk of
starving her to see if this could
mitigate the generation of candies but
when denied sugary Foods Miss sweetie
would double over in pain wailing about
the agony she felt the head researcher
at the provisional site was horrified by
the notion of torturing an anomaly that
had done no intentional harm to anyone
and insisted they find another way one
researcher Dr o'hairly proposed a
solution why not try a sugar substitute
they decided to test it out giving
scp-2396 a liter of liquid sucralose
while behave saving as though it was her
ordinary dose of sugar she accepted it
graciously and made no complaints of
pain at all after switching to the
sucralose the candy stopped appearing
Miss sweetie was reclassified as Euclid
and moved to psych 19. after a week of
the sucralose base containment
procedures Dr o'heary conducted her
fifth interview with
scp-2396 for the sake of avoiding any
potential outbursts Miss sweetie was led
to believe that she was still producing
candy as well as living candy creatures
a transcript of this interview is
included in
scp-2396's official file Dr o'hearley
sat down at the table where Miss sweetie
was already waiting with a pleasant
smile on her face good morning
scp-2396 Dr oh Healy began Miss sweetie
scoffed and giggled at this opener oh
come on Cindy you don't have to be all
stuffy With Your Best gal Dr o'healley
responded with a polite smile neglecting
to correct scp-2396 on the fact that
Cindy was not in fact her real name
alright scp-2396 are you aware another
scp-2396-b attempted to breach your
containment she referred here to one of
Miss sweetie's candy soldiers miss sweet
giggled that's just boys always got to
be making a big stink of things when
they want to get your attention and it
always like that never a man always a
boy always beating up their friends when
they think they're getting too close the
man's always got to have his hands busy
or else they're going to be in the air
Dr o'heary pressed the matter they seem
to be concentrating on taking you away
from here are you unhappy here
scp-2396 miss sweetie's side a woman
ain't happy anywhere isn't that what
they say Dr o'hillie frowned I'm not
aware of any such saying Miss sweetie
Shrugged it should be one I don't know
Lucy I just think it's because every gal
wants this big strong bug to sweep her
off her feet and these are sweet boys
deep down even if they're sticky I'm
sure they'd sweep you off your feet too
if you girls asked Dr o'hearley thought
about commenting on the inherent sexism
and heteronormativity of this statement
but thought better of it she also
considered pointing out that Lucy was
not her name either
shook it off then what about the
instances that resemble unicorns Miss
sweetie lit up at the mention of these
don't you just love unicorns all little
girls love unicorns you can eat them too
when you get bored little girls get
bored it's good to have boys and
unicorns you can eat when you're
finished isn't that a little reductive
Dr o'hearley replied Miss sweetie
appeared to become irritated she rolled
her eyes look toots I'm a girl's toy and
it's a man's world what do you want from
me is that why you repel men because
you're a girl's toy Miss sweetie nodded
Dr W didn't like it when boys break
their sister's toys told me it was damn
near the worst thing in the world and
they can't break me they can't even come
near me well except with her you know
all sweet and handsome and you're happy
with the way things are Dr o'hearley
asked Miss sweetie pause for a moment to
consider then answered Dr W's code in my
book I always had a sweet tooth and I
always wanted to be a girl kind of an
okay trade-off if you ask me you guys
ain't so bad though even if the food's
crap don't know how you mess up sugar
Sarah but you guys make it taste like
crap aside from complaining about its
taste and no longer being able to
produce any of her anomalous candy the
sucralose substitute had no adverse
effects on
scp-2396 at this point in time no
containment measures Beyond this dietary
change and making sure all staff that
interact with her identify as women have
been necessary so miss sweetie sits in
her cell in the low security wing of
Psych 19 missing her favorite sugary
Treats but otherwise content with the
way things are and on the outside no
more unsuspecting boys are being
transformed into confectionary against
their will just to be safe though if
you're ever out walking and you see
pieces of delicious looking hard candies
scattered along the ground just remember
what your parents always said don't take
candy from strangers you just never know
where it came from we all have that one
toy from our childhood we held near and
dear to our hearts from stuffed bears to
action figures every child has something
meaningful to them that they clung to it
may have been a gift from a parent or
grandparent or maybe it was an old
family Memento passed down from
generation to generation regardless
those of us who have these toys became
extremely connected to them physically
and emotionally perhaps you talked to
this toy like it was your friend or
clung to it during nights where it was
storming in order to comfort yourself
what if these toys were giving the same
feelings back towards us and we didn't
realize it it's a question that only
those in the universe of the SCP
Foundation could find a proper answer to
scp-174
ventriloquists dummy it was a normal day
for scp-174 and its owner Marion
nine-year-old girl had a pretty ordinary
existence for a girl her age a a room
decorated in pink and obvious fashion
her school books and art supplies sat on
her little desk in the corner and all of
her dolls and toys neatly sat on the
shelves on the wall she wakes up around
8 o'clock for her third grade classes at
the nearby Elementary School where she
is driven to by her father every day she
gets dressed quickly in her school
uniform
scp-174 remembers a long blue skirt
white button-up shirt and flat black
shoes this was routine
scp-174 watched her every day to the
point it became part of its expected
daily regimen Mary Ventures out of the
room with a quick goodbye to all her
lovely toys
scp-174 being among her favorites if not
her absolute favorite toy to play with
for hours scp-174 would sit on the
shelves of Mary's room staring at the
same pink wall all day long waiting in
pure excitement and happiness for the
room door to get pushed back open so
play time can begin once again Mary
loved the toy and oddly enough the toy
loved Mary back most kids would probably
find scp-174 creepy ventriloquist's
dummies are not often thought of as cute
or cuddly or even good playtime friends
but Mary didn't care she and scp-174 had
so much fun together that she didn't
even comprehend the fact that it might
be creepy never mind a thought about
what other people might think all the
dressing up making up stories and living
them out from Brave princes saving
princesses to evil dragons or Pirates
taking on the seven seas in search of
treasures
scp-174 had fun playing along with
Mary's childhood imagination her Joy was
its Joy it was more than enough for Mary
to be happy and in turn
scp-174 was also happy it remembers the
day it was brought out of the dingy
attic where it was forgotten left to
dust and cobwebs to pop file up on it
over time
scp-174 was a creation of Mary's
grandfather a now retired ventriloquist
performer and a master of it at that
scp-174 didn't mind the work but it
wasn't loved like it was now it was just
a prop to be used for laughs and money
but now it was something someone
actually cared about the Glorious
afternoon when Mary discovered him in a
storage bin was a day it wouldn't forget
as it now felt loved and appreciated by
someone Mary didn't want money out of
scp-174 nor did she want fame she just
wanted a friend an scp-174 was going to
give as much as it could to her as Mary
Grew Older it seemed playtime had become
rarer and rarer it went from multiple
times a day to once or maybe twice a
night on a good day to once a week and
now Mary a 16 year old girl didn't look
like she had the time anymore books and
papers piled up on her bed from nights
of studying her attention was grabbed by
her cell phone and late night calls with
her friends and on the weekends when her
and scp-174 would usually spend the most
time together in the past she wasn't
even in the house anymore never mind in
a room and by the time she came back she
was too tired to want to do anything she
didn't talk to it anymore and barely
even looked at it at most scp-174 would
receive a passing glance and a weak
smile but at least she still knew it was
there and that for what it was was
enough for scp-174 to be content two
more years passed and now Mary was 18.
she had grown up so much as cp-174
thought to itself it was a cool day as
the dusk of Summer was upon Mary City
August was coming to a close and Autumn
was steadily creeping up on them but for
some reason Mary hadn't been preparing
for school there was no backpack instead
of a variety of suitcases and bins lined
her room take picking up most of the
space that was previously empty clothes
hangers lay on her bed and Mary's mother
was organizing her clothes into two
piles it looked like Mary was moving out
but that wasn't true right she's never
left without her Playmate and her best
friend right after two days of packing
and preparing it seemed Mary was ready
to leave to wherever she was going as
cp-174 hoped it wasn't going to be for
too long perhaps it's a vacation or a
short School field trip had thought but
the fateful day of Mary's departure had
arrived the room was completely cleared
out and other than her pink walls and
floral comforter almost everything was
gone Mary popped back into the room
suitcase in hand looked around and left
without a word no goodbye she didn't
even look at scp-174
scp-174 was devastated months passed
without a sign of Mary
scp-174 heard phones ringing and faint
Whispers of her voice through telephone
line but it wasn't enough
scp-174 missed its friend on one fateful
night as cp-174 was met with rings and
alarms The house's fire alarm system
smoke permeated the air and it began to
grow warmer and warmer than hotter than
so hot it couldn't bear the pain all
scp-174 could do was sit there and wait
for someone something to save it but no
one came
scp-174 woke up wet and charred under a
pile of dirt Ash and wood it could spot
daylight through the cracks and crevices
of the mound that pinned it down it laid
there for what felt like ours before it
heard a familiar voice Mom Dad the voice
was met with sobering responses hello
sweetie and sorry I had to see this we
don't know what happened it was Mary
back from wherever she went and her
family was here now they could all be
back together as cp-174 thought we have
a few things that survived the fire your
piles of over there Mary's mother said
it's not much but at least it's
something footsteps grew louder towards
scp-174 the pile above it grew lighter
and lighter as the face of its best
friend came clearer and clearer into
view
scp-174 wasn't met with a face of
happiness or joy like it expected more
one of fear and disgust do you see
anything her father asked nothing I want
Mary responded coldly before leaving the
pile all
scp-174 wanted was a friend someone it
could care for and would care for it it
tried its best but now it gets that all
meant nothing to marry
scp-174 closed its eyes and with a
gut-wrenching feeling of Despair listen
to the voice of its former best friend
slowly fade away it was a few days
months years or even decades before
scp-174 reawoke it wasn't with a new
loving family or in the room of a child
who might play with it again now this
was not where was it was in a cold
locker with its only light being from
the slits of the locked door that kept
it contained sadness was all that
scp-174 could feel and it's all anyone
around as cp-174 could feel its sadness
was so powerful it was influencing those
around it to pity it maybe then they'd
play with it but there is no playing in
what scp-174 would learn to be the SCP
Foundation the SCP Foundation conducted
its standard amount of research on the
anomaly they asked the same questions
they always did what object class do we
give this anomaly initially they gave it
safe it would stay in a box and they
didn't have to watch it plus it didn't
pose a reasonable amount of danger but
would the SCP Foundation be correct in
its assessment of the object class
scp-174 was marked as a safe class low
security object up until May 14 2013.
this was a special day for scp-174 while
not exactly for 174 but for Mary it was
Mary's 19th birthday but scp-174 was not
there to wish her that its sadness grew
and grew maybe if it was there for her
she would love it again maybe if it was
there on this day they could play again
just once just one more time they could
be friends again and scp-174 could be
happy again with all its strength
scp-174 moved itself for the first time
a doctor later discovered scp-174
sitting on the floor next to its
containment unit looking directly at the
main entrance Door the doctor hastily
placed scp-174 back into its storage
locker and later the foundation would
install surveillance cameras
scp-174 watched the entire process
through the slits in its storage locker
even more discouraging the foundation
also implanted as cp-174 with a tracking
device all hope was lost for a CP 174 to
see Mary again but it couldn't forget
her no matter how hard it tried it grew
sadder and sadder to understand
scp-174 better we need to take a look at
the SCP foundation's file on scp-174
scp-174 is a wooden ventriloquist dummy
with severe damage seen on the figure
scp-174 has a number of anomalous
properties could it be that scp-174
sadness and grief over losing its friend
was so great that scp-174 developed
these properties it's possible but the
SCP Foundation is still unsure when
viewed in a person's peripheral vision
it has been reported that as cp-174 will
look at them with an expression of
longing or sadness in general anyone in
the vicinity of scp-174 will grow sad or
direct sympathy at
scp-174 the SCP Foundation later
discovered that anyone who places
scp-174 on their hand feels the urge to
talk to the entity those who have put
scp-174 on their hand will report to
researchers that all scp-174 wants is a
friend that it could talk to those who
wear scp-174 for longer periods of time
will begin speaking in a high-pitched
childlike voice the foundation believes
that this is the voice of scp-174 now
changing the roles of ventriloquist and
ventriloquist dummy as the person
wearing scp-174 is the dummy the subject
will begin to converse with itself
through their own voice and scp-174 in
all cases 174 will tell it's where that
it was abandoned and left to the trash
by Mary it would tell them how much it
missed Mary how sad it was and how angry
it was getting
scp-174 learned quickly how easy it
could trick these people into feeling
bad for it it went from telling the
truth about what happened to it to
changing its story over and over again
to the point that the SCP Foundation has
no idea what what the true story is and
they have no idea about Mary stories of
being left at a playground to being
thrown out or left on a stage by a
performer began to become commonplace
anything
scp-174 could think of it would use to
manipulate the person wearing it
scp-174 knows the truth however but
maybe it's easier for it to lie and
forget the trauma it experienced is it
possible that scp-174 is becoming
corrupted in a way it was also learned
that scp-174's fake stories about its
past will have a direct connection to
the subject that is wearing it so if you
remember a time you might have been
bullied as a child or lost a toy or
anything that might have been something
negative
scp-174 will use that for its own
sympathy the loss of its first owner has
completely changed scp-174's outlook on
life and now it wants to make a friend
by any means necessary even manipulation
through anomalous mean means scp-174
developed a series of telepathic
abilities to further its manipulation
for sympathy a d-class was ordered to
wear 174. the dolls burned and battered
appearance left the d-class hesitant doc
you sure I have to wear this creepy
thing please proceed with the test
d14285 the doctor responded coldly we
know the foundation is okay with putting
morals aside for their tests so this
answer should have been obvious to the
d-class Personnel
d14285 lifted scp-174 and placed it on
her right hand and a conversation with
the anomaly began what happened to you
d-14285 asked quietly there was a fire
d-14285 said in a high-pitched voice
mimicking scp-174 hi
the d-class said almost on the verge of
tears
burglars they broke into a house my
house and began to steal anything
valuable desha back in her normal voice
d14285 responded that that happened to
my family I'm so sorry to hear that you
don't deserve that she said in her
high-pitched voice the burglars they
were stealing everything
golden jewelry money pictures even
pieces of art my owner painted all the
memories he made were being stolen
my father was an artist
d14285 said in her normal voice
burned but I was the only one who lived
the performer who only died trying to
rescue me the d-class says in the voice
of scp-174 he was trying to save me but
but the Flames day
they consumed him now now I have no
fringe anymore
will you will you will you be my friend
d14285 breaks down into tears and
returns to her normal voice I'm sorry
she says through sobs I I'm so sorry oh
I'll be your friend the observing
researcher begins to yell cancel the
test immediately there's clearly
something more going on here guards
enter the testing chamber upon the
researchers orders and begin to restrain
d14285 and remove the manipulative
anomaly from her arm the d-class begins
to scream and cry no no no they took it
from me my baby she begins to fight
against the restraining security guards
but is dragged out kicking and screaming
while calling for scp-174 who lays
Motionless in the corner of the testing
chamber it was found that b-class
amnestics were effective in quelling the
lingering effects of scp-174 however if
left untreated those affected by a
cp-174's influence and manipulation are
similar in Behavior to those of mothers
separated from their children sadly the
test that led to the discovery of
domestics being useful in stopping
scp-174's manipulative effects were
found after
d14285's test as she was terminated due
to her not being able to be consoled and
her cries constantly being disruptive
before her termination the foundation
found a number of abnormalities in her
behavior
d-14285 would only ever talk about
scp-174 regardless of topic of
conversation or questions asked to her
she would only respond with the same
frantic line of questions or statements
is the doll okay can I see him what did
you do to him why would you let me see
him I was supposed to be friends with
him please let me please tell me he's
all right this effect does not persist
as it normally goes away after a few
hours or days but in some cases like
d14285 this effect will endure to the
point of obsession and depression as
such scp-174's object class has been
changed to a Euclid level anomaly the
SCP Foundation deals with anomalies of
varying danger and containment
difficulty we are familiar with ones
that look dangerous and act even more
dangerous from scp-096 the shy guy to
the employees of scp-3008 the infinite
Ikea or even scp-049 the plague doctor
and its Touch of death but what might be
even more dangerous is when the SCP
Foundation discovers an anomaly that
does not look dangerous in the slightest
perhaps that's why they initially placed
an extremely manipulative and dangerous
anomaly into safe class storage the SCP
Foundation is known for its cold tactics
and cruel experiments but in the case of
scp-174 it was extremely important to
test the anomaly in order to know how
dangerous it really was
scp-174 is the story of a toy that was
held near and dear during childhood
similar to the ones we can all
potentially have the play times in
childhood innocence carried those bonds
deeper than we may think in the case of
scp-174 it was used during this period
then pushed aside once its former friend
Mary grew up and had to focus on her
life outside of the world of imagination
this turned scp-174 into a cold monster
who wants that connection and bond back
by any means necessary it puppeteers
people in order to get sympathy
manipulating them by using their own
traumatic stories against them in a sick
twisted attempt to make what it thinks a
friend is if you happen to still have
your favorite childhood toy laying
around somewhere in your house it might
be a good idea to go show it some love
like literally go grab that Tickle Me
Elmo or Hannah Montana singing doll and
give it a hug tell it it's still
appreciated for all the fun times
because while there may be consequences
to your actions or lack thereof
anomalous creatures in the SCP
foundation's Universe are not a rarity
dealing with anomalous Sapien life forms
is the foundation's bread and butter
whether it's talkative sea slugs or a
body stealing swarm of ants for those of
you who haven't read their Ethics
Committee guidebooks Sapient anomalies
are defined as creatures who have a keen
sense of self-awareness and can
communicate from the zaniness of Dr
bright and his amulet to the neck
cracking SCP-173 these Sapient anomalous
entities come in all shapes and sizes
but when does a creature become so
Sapient they can be considered anomalous
take the humble octopus for example who
also just so happens to be the subject
of today's video the octopus is a
boneless eight-legged creature capable
of Shifting the color and texture of its
skin and Will Blast Predators with a
black substance to Blind them if I read
that in an SCP Foundation file I might
think those researchers found an alien
creature but no octopi or octopodes are
as you know real living breathing
creatures you can see at any aquarium
another interesting Quirk of octopods is
their intelligence these creatures are
smart extremely smart how they'll even
use Fallen coconuts as a sort of armor
against enemies if tool use isn't
intelligence I don't know what is you
may be wondering how can you make an
octopus more anomalous than what I've
already described well today on SCP
explained we'll be taking a look at
scp-2967 the Sapient cephalopods to
answer that exact question we have all
probably been to aquariums dark ambient
rooms where the only light comes from
behind the massive tanks filled to the
brim with colorful fish and Crustaceans
they can be fun to explore but when
you've seen a bunch of exotic fish once
it's not like you're clamoring to get
back in soon this was the problem faced
by the Galaxy aquarium in May of 2010
attendance was low and profit was lower
the owner of the aquarium was a man by
the name of Mark Hemphill he was young
and extremely ambitious Mark had an
interest in marine life since he was a
child and dedicated his life to studying
the creatures of the sea when he opened
the aquarium he had just gotten out of
college he hoped his passion and his
aquarium would Inspire even just one
child to pursue the study of marine life
as he did Mark's ambitious personality
was not going to let him watch his
life's work go to waste at a nearby
Auction House the anomalous group of
Interest Marshall Carter and dark were
organizing a showing for their new batch
of anonymous creatures available for
bidding seasoned viewers of SCP
explained have likely run into anomalies
that Marshall Carter and dark have had a
hand in for those not in the loop
Marshall Carter and dark are dealers of
anomalous goods and services selling
anomalies to the highest bidder no
matter who they are from the average Joe
to a tyrannical dictator Marshall Carter
and dark only care about Cold Hard Cash
and getting as much of it as they can
Mark hearing whispers of a massive
auction coming up decided to attend he
entered the auction house an old
dilapidated Warehouse on the sketchy
side of town not exactly inspiring
confidence but Mark thought maybe just
maybe there would be something for him
to add to his aquarium to get more
attendees marked walked through the
heavy metal doors to an Immaculate
auction space the building was loaded
with well-dressed individuals who gazed
over the items they had for sale wooden
tables lined the walls of the warehouse
and on top of each table were tanks and
cages of creatures Mark never thought
could exist from dogs that smelled like
candles two purple frogs that
telepathically communicated with the
people around them Mark was convinced
that there was something here he could
use a staff member approached Mark
almost immediately it was as if the
staff could smell the willingness to
spend money on him she was an older
woman dressed in a fine purple hewed
suit she spoke with a comforting Candor
to Mark asking him about his day and
what brought him to the auction house
she introduced herself as Jay and said
that the auction house had just the
thing for Mark before he could even get
the words out they walked to the
opposite side of the building where a
purple curtain was erected walking
through it was as if Mark had returned
back to his aquarium what were the odds
that this place would have a marine life
section oddly for such a well-designed
room there was only one small tank
placed in it within it was six octopodes
a pale yellow in color Mark immediately
recognized the species as the common
octopus the Galaxy aquarium already had
a cephalopod section with much more rare
species than the common octopus dejected
Mark almost gave up hope before Jay
approached the tank and kneeled Jay
seemed concerned and called out the name
Levi from under the table on which the
tank stood a massive octopus slithered
into sight startling mark it was at
least five feet in height and length
that's possible Mark thought there's no
way that an octopus of this species
could get to be this large the octopus's
size was not the only Oddity it held
though Jay began to scold Levi for
leaving its tank and asked what it had
to say for itself she threw a Sharpie
marker to the ground for Levi who
uncapped it and began to write out the
word sorry on the concrete floor this
couldn't be Mark thought there was
absolutely no way that an octopus can
learn to understand English let alone
ride it Jay turned to Mark encouraging
him to talk to Levi uh what's your name
Mark as sheepishly he couldn't believe
he was trying to talk to an octopus as
soon as the words left his mouth the
octopus spelled out
l-e-v-i with its marker mark couldn't
believe it this had to be some trick
right some sort of marketing gimmick to
get him to buy an overgrown piece of
calamari there is no way that an octopus
could have self-awareness Mark knew they
were smart of course he had studied
these things for years but knowing its
name that's not possible what are you
Mark questioned hoping to figure out if
it was an animatronic instead of a
living breathing animal Levi began to
ride on the floor again not a word this
time but a symbol the octopus first drew
a large oval then eight lines coming
from the bottom a crude drawing of an
octopus behind Levi the other six
octopodes were watching him as
Spectators seeming to clap when Levi
finished the drawing Jay with a smug
grin on her face asked Mark if he was
impressed the look on Mark's face
already told the story so Jay began to
go over the pricing of the creatures
Levi and the other six octopodes were a
package deal with a starting bid for all
seven placed at three thousand dollars
Mark without a second thought asked if
he could outright purchase Levi and his
compatriots for ten thousand dollars Jay
smile grew wider and she shook Mark's
hand without another word said Levi and
the six other octopodes were delivered
to the Galaxy aquarium the next day
within that time Mark had already
prepared an unused section for the
arrival of his new attraction the
cephalopods were placed in their tanks
without much difficulty and settled into
their new home advertising began for the
Galaxy aquarium's newest attraction the
talking octopus Mark even splurged on a
billboard on the nearby Highway this
investment was meant to save the
aquarium and for the next few months
attendance skyrocketed now we know why
the SCP Foundation keeps a heavy watch
over anomalous entities in the public
because all it takes is one ambitious
person before the entire world knows
that anomalies exist with the popularity
of Levi it was a matter of time before
the SCP Foundation heard of it it was
time for an investigation site-12 was a
site dedicated to marine life and as
such many of the Personnel station there
had the appropriate expertise to deal
with the anomaly agent Hooper
volunteered for the investigation He was
ordered to pose as an animal behavior
specialist from the sea coral Pacific
Federation real creative there SCP
Foundation it just so happened that at
the same time agent Hooper was getting
involved Levi was beginning to give Mark
a hard time at his aquarium it was a
late night in January 2011. the aquarium
had since closed after another day of
almost full attendance Levi was not
sleeping however he was hungry and by
coincidence the section of the Galaxy
aquarium next to Levi's tank was a
potential all you could eat buffet
should his plan come to fruition the
next day aquarium staff awoke to the
filtration system of the crab enclosure
being blocked by one of Levi's friends
it was quickly removed and placed back
into its proper tank it wasn't out of
the ordinary for octopodes to escape
their tanks as I explained there are
smart creatures aquarium staff began the
process of moving the crabs to a
temporary tank while repairs and
cleaning on the original tank were
taking place as their attention was
drawn to the damaged filter and
contaminated crab tank Levi managed to
escape and enter the unguarded temporary
tank of crabs broken shells and water
splattered the floor of the temporary
tank room as the feast began it was a
massacre Levi ate 20 of the 40 crabs and
another 10 were dropped off into the
octopus's tank for Levi's comrades
satisfied with its meal Levi returned to
his tank as if nothing had happened an
hour passed before the leftovers of
Levi's dinner were discovered and it
didn't take much guessing on the part of
aquarium staff to deduce who was behind
this agent Hooper arrived the next day
and asked to meet with Mark Hooper
explained that he was from the sea coral
Pacific Federation and his place of
employment had heard of Levi and wanted
to study him Mark like a moth to a flame
eagerly took the opportunity to describe
the remarkable events of the previous
day Hooper nodded along with the story
and promised to figure out why Levi was
acting this way agent Hooper was
escorted to the talking octopus section
of the aquarium and asked for some
privacy which he was granted Levi was
sitting on a large mound of sand while
the smaller octopods sat in front of as
if they were intently listening Levi was
apparently lecturing the group using a
sharp Rock to carve words and pictures
on the Plexiglas walls of the tank agent
Hooper knocked on the glass startling
the group in Anger Levi swam to the
front of the tank and stared at agent
Hooper with a tentacle it knocked hard
on the glass and then endeavored to
return to its lecture agent Hooper
didn't catch the hint that he was
unwelcome and stayed uncomfortably close
to the glass until Levi couldn't ignore
the agent any longer the octopus held up
five tentacles and made a shoeing motion
towards Hooper who was incredibly
surprised Hoover recognized the motion
as the phrase go away in Sign Language
Hooper responded asking Levi sign
language in sign language in response
Levi once again held up five tentacles
and created what appeared to be a fist
then bobbed it back and forth like a
head nodding an octopus that knows sign
language not the most dangerous or
extraordinary anomaly that the
foundation has ever discovered but still
this anomaly could not remain out of
containment Hooper quickly contacted the
research head at site 12 and explained
the situation he needed a containment
van for an aquatic anomaly a containment
force and Class A amnestics immediately
this request was granted Foundation
mobile task force Lambda 12 Pest Control
stormed the building and wrangled the
aquarium staff into a closet so they
couldn't interfere the agents were
dressed in their tactical armor and held
large rifles but this was only to show
that they were meant to be taken
seriously and not to be used for force a
white unmarked containment van arrived
soon after Foundation researchers ran
into the building and transported Levi
and his students into the temporary
tanks of the containment van and made
sure they were securely closed and
locked multiple times when each octopus
was secured an Airborne version of
A-Class amnestics was distributed
throughout the aquarium by the mobile
task force agents leading to all
knowledge of Levi being forgotten by the
aquarium staff and Mark for further
containment the SCP Foundation
distributed liquid amnestics into the
city's water supply so that anyone who
saw one of Levi's performances would
forget that it ever happened the SCP
Foundation classified Levi as
scp-2967 and discovered the full extent
of its anomalous attributes
scp-2967 of course has the ability to
communicate through written language is
able to recognize and identify colors
symbols and individual figures of other
species and holds an abnormally High
intellect almost comparable to an
average human's intelligence the six
comrades of
scp-2967 were designated as
scp-2967-1 as they do not seem to be at
the same level of intellect as
scp-2967 through behavioral analysis and
research it was found that
scp-2967 will refer to
scp-2967-1 as its students friends or
Army Dr Reynard the head researcher on
the scp-2967 anomaly began hosting
intelligence checkups on
scp-2967 every two weeks these consisted
of Levi talking to Dr Reynard through
the use of a waterproof magnetic slate
while the doctor asked Levi questions on
one such occasion the foundation
discovered that there may be more
creatures similar to
scp-2967 and its students Dr Renard
began by drawing a crab an octopus and
scp-2967's toy he labeled them crab
friend and toy on its slate
scp-2967 wrote like and then a sketch of
a heart Dr Anar drew a check mark on his
clipboard before rewarding
scp-2967 with a prawn following up Dr
Reynard asked if there was anything Levi
didn't like to display this concept Dr
Raynard Drew an X over a heart symbol
Levi pause for a moment seeming to think
then then Drew what appeared to be a
bird with outstretched wings and an
angular beak Upon finishing the drawing
the octopus's skin changed to a deep red
color Levi wrote don't no word on his
slate then returned to its normal
colorization Renard despite a photo of a
pigeon to Levi who marked an x on his
slate signifying that there was
something wrong before shifting its skin
black in response Dr Reynard returned to
a picture of a crow to Levi who
scrambled to write on its slate that
word it wrote hastily Renard responded
Crow with his Newfound knowledge Levi
drew a heart with an X through it on its
slate then spelled out don't like Crow
Dr Renard was confused how did two
species of creatures who live in
completely different habitats have a
disdain for each other
scp-2967 began to explain Levi sketched
an octopus a crow in what appeared to be
a human over the head of the human Levi
drone Arrow pointing at the human before
drawing a check mark over the sketch of
the octopus and the crow Levi connected
the check marks to the arrow above the
human with two lines it seemed that the
crows and the octopodes disdain come
from their common ability to connect and
grow fond of humans the intelligence
check included after Levi explained this
to Dr Renard as the octopus claimed it
was tired and wanted to return to its
containment chamber the next day however
it seemed that
scp-2967 had correctly predicted what
would happen at site 12. on April 3rd
2011 research staff at site 12 reported
a high concentration of American crows
surrounding the building many were
perched in trees or on the roof of the
site but some were simply hovering near
the entrances seeming to hope that the
door would open while the crows weren't
aggressive to humans it would fly to a
window connected to the containment
chamber of
scp-2967 and peck on it this continued
for hours and it seems that the crows
were threatening Levi and friends the
foundation deployed mobile task force
Lambda 4 bird watchers to site 12. this
team was not armed in your standard
tactical gear and heavy Weaponry they
wore camouflage clothing with shoes that
muffled their Footsteps in grassy
environments they had jackets of thick
leather to prevent injuries from Talons
or beaks and they had specialized pellet
guns they used to incapacitate anomalous
Birds they began by shooting the birds
away and capturing a few using meds for
further study as they concluded all but
one of the crows dispersed this Crow was
similar to Levi much larger compared to
non-anomalous members of its species the
large Crow flew 10 feet from the
entrance of the site and spat the decang
remains of one common octopus out onto
the asphalt parking lot before
retreating the bird watchers attempted
to follow the group of crows but the
flock was impossible to track what was
found however was an area in a nearby
Forest that contained an abnormally
large number of feathers belonging to
the American crow species as well as
numerous small makeshift Huts made of
sticks and dying leaves and a collection
of various litter fashioned in two basic
tools such as hammers made of bolts and
toothbrushes the most surprising item
retrieved during this exploration was
the torn remnants of a copy of the
documentation for
scp-2967 kept in the largest Hut as is
standard the SCP Foundation enacted
surveillance procedures on this location
placing hidden cameras and microphones
as well as traps the large Crow has been
classified as
scp-2967-b so it seems that the animal
kingdom is at War for the favor of the
human race while the foundation Only
Knows for sure that octopodes and crows
are at Battle there may be many more
species out there who look to Curry our
favor who do you think will be the
victors should battle commends art is an
elusive Specter it can be harder to
catch than scp-682 harder to explain
than SC
p055 and have as profound effects on our
minds as
scp-035 it exists in our hearts and our
brains it's something we can both
discover and impose paintings sculptures
performance music film photography
animation game design and so much more
exists under its umbrella Thomas Merton
once said art enables us to find
ourselves and lose ourselves at the same
time and we here at SCP explained are
inclined to agree even the video you're
watching right now is a kind of art it's
the product of hard work by writers
editors animators a voice artist hello
and the producers who bring it all
together really where would we be
without it but of course there's always
going to be people out there who want to
push the boundaries of art just that
little bit further the avant-garde
artists who work on the fringes Pioneers
willing to delve further into the
darkest corners of human experience and
sometimes even Beyond that's right
welcome to the wonderful and weird world
of an artists a word that in and of
itself has a kind of artistry to it it's
short for anomalous artists as in
artists who work with the medium of
explicitly anomalous objects or
materials the more perceptive among you
may have also noticed its similarity to
the word anarchists as in rejecters of
rigid rules and order like the kind
imposed by the SCP Foundation and when
it comes to the world of an artists
you'll find that a certain group comes
up again and again and again are we cool
yet you've probably heard of it before
in passing but there's a lot about this
anomalous Art Collective that remains
mysterious until today we're going to
grab our Berets and paint stained aprons
and dive deep into the an art scene as
well as their most controversial group
of Interest one thing is for sure it's
going to get incredibly incredibly
strange from here on in but hey it's art
what can you expect the structure and
reputation of are we cool yet is a
complicated and contentious topic even
within the world of an art much like the
Serpent's hand the group is incredibly
decentralized with no governing body or
binding ethos save for the commitment to
produce an art proponents of are we cool
yet think of it as a kind of binding
ethos someone can become a member of our
week cool yet without even knowing about
the group beforehand this is why as long
as the memory and reputation of the
group remains alive the SCP Foundation
can't effectively shut them down some
work under the banner of are we cool yet
alone toiling away driven by sheer
passion for the art they create others
work in Creative salons typically led by
a smaller group of artistic Visionaries
working to turn their combined skills
into more ambitious varieties of an art
a common philosophy of the group is
wanting to make their art visible to the
world often to make a statement or start
a discussion among the public naturally
this particular Drive is liable to make
local Foundation authorities burst a
blood vessel or maybe they really just
don't get armed I mean look at Dr gears
especially does he strike you as the
kind of guy who would take some time out
of his day to stroll around a gallery
he'd probably murmur some snide comment
about it being a waste of printing paper
anyway before we proceed further into
are we cool yet as it is today its
relationship with other groups of
Interest its Splinter cells and some of
its notable Creations its members have
produced we need to go back to the past
and discuss the group's creation
thankfully this group's history can be
traced back to the 1800s rather than us
needing to trace it all the way back to
the creation of humanity and the
universe like the Church of the broken
God or the children of the Scarlet King
the rather amazing thing about this
particular group is that its whole
identity can be traced back to an
argument between two famous artists
Marcel Duchamp and Ruiz Marcos for those
who need a little refresher on art
history duchamp's most famous pieces are
probably Fountain the iconic signed
urinal an l h o o q the painting of the
Mona Lisa defaced with a mustache and a
goatee and Ruiz Marcos is best known for
painting the colors in your darkest
nightmares that strange feeling you get
at an empty train station in the middle
of the night and the subtle whiff of
burnt toast you get before a cerebral
event the following is a critical
extract from the coolest War memories of
a Critic an anonymously penned Opus on
the nature of an art and the creation of
are we cool yet detailing the group's
early history and defining embryonic
moments in the 19th century the march of
progress made it possible for the first
time for human science to contemplate
and comprehend those phenomenon which
had long seemed to contravene the laws
of nature within a matter of decades
Concepts that had long been viewed as
witchcraft or sorcery were laid bare in
the terms of a new and secret science
and governments and organizations around
the world again to classify study and
collect all such anomalies and just as
artists throughout history have turned a
critical eye to the events of the day in
their work so too did the artists of
this scientific Renaissance begin to
interpret these new discoveries on
canvas by the 1870s Paris was the center
of the world of anomalous art and the
city stood witness to endless debates
about the role of the anomalous in art
but whether such a role existed at all
when in 1874 the famous salon Des
magnifiques refused to allow any works
of a phantasmagorical nature to be
displayed at the Grand exhibition those
artists shut out by the committee
organized their own counter-exhibition
to be held at the same time across the
river
new magnific as the show came to be
called was the talk of the Parisian
press for months earning equal amounts
of curiosity dismal and outright
derision but the exiled gab flies had
made their point the Paranormal the
anomalous and the bizarre had found a
place in the world of Art and would not
be so easily gotten rid of some knew the
Avenue Magnifique held its exhibitions
every 10 years thereafter and as time
passed the world of anomalous art grew
larger from its Beginnings in Paris
artists from all across France and
Europe and later from the Americas and
the Orient as well began attending the
increasingly prestigious and
increasingly bizarre and difficult to
keep hidden from the disdainful eyes of
a concerned government exhibition
expressing new and different
interpretations of the role of the
anomalous in human life it was at the
sixth decennial exhibition in 1924 that
the growing Rift between the two largest
schools of thought logical versus
emotional science versus Faith aldwell
versus new came to a head but it was at
that show that For the First Time The
Works of the French surrealist Marcel
Duchamp would be exhibited alongside
those of Ruiz Marcos the Mexican artist
whose themes of magical realism and
religious are intertwined with the
viscerally accessible fortenia of our
world had said art critics were wide at
war with each other those who saw the
two during the days leading up to the
openings of the exhibition said they
spent nearly the entire time in heated
discussion with one another in English
for neither spoke the other's mother
tongue confidently that everything under
the sun the importance of the artists in
relation to his work the importance of
context Faith knowledge law free will
God the state democracy Marxism the war
of the League of Nations and the best
way to serve a cup of coffee it seemed
that they might continue bickering
through the entire exhibition but as the
artist prepared to greet the assembled
press on the morning of its grand
opening they appeared to have eventually
come to an understanding if there is one
image that comes to mind of any art
historian when the 1924 Expo is brought
up it is of that iconic photo of Duchamp
and Ruiz posing side by side with their
fellow artists in front of the steel
closed doors Marco seemingly leaning
over to Whispers something in duchamp's
ear for decades many have speculated on
what words Marcos had for his colleague
during that memorable instant a question
of metaphysics or a challenge an
affirmation of their Coming to Terms a
reminder of the reason why they were
there at that moment of time perhaps as
an expression of Amazement at the
multitudes that had come to see them
according to one reporter who claimed he
stood close enough to overhear that
whisper admits the din of the crowd it
was all five at once expressed in four
simple words are we cool yet as you can
see the themes that run through the
entirety of this group of interests got
their start early on the leading ones
are conflict and the desire to prove
oneself being excluded from the
prestigious 19th century French Art
Salon salandes Magnifique led to them
creating their iconic Gathering and
exhibition some new devenu Magnifique
which translates Loosely to Have We
Become magnificent an ironic jab about
gatekeeping in the art world to have
one's anarch featured at some new diving
new Magnifique held only once every 10
years is the greatest honor for any
artist that that is a devotee of are we
cool yet and their practices however
something that is extremely important to
note is that this doesn't necessarily
apply to all an artists out there after
all and artists like all creative
Spirits have a tendency to be highly
individualistic and some have bones to
pick with the way that are we cool yet
operates one notable Splinter Group
broke away in 2013 to form a far smaller
group of interests known as Gamers
against weed The Gamers didn't exactly
jive with the fact that some of the
anarch made by the members of are we
cool yet hurt people specifically the
founder of Gamers against weed Jude
creont lost a friend to a dangerous
piece of an art at an are we cool yet
exhibition The Gamers also just found
that are we cool yet had a weirdly
intense energy that seriously harshened
their Vibe and as a result they went
their own direction to perform more
harmless and Goofy anomalous pranks like
creating scp-3108 the nerfing gun and
scp-2586 Mr literal serial killer and we
swear that's less nasty than it sounds
the violence that this particular Art
Collective allows is a point of
contention among a lot of an artists
some ex-members have joined the more
pacifistic sex of the Serpent's hand
where they can still follow their dreams
of exposing the anomalous to the public
without needing to rub elbows with the
kind of people who believe that our
projects have a certain amount of
acceptable casualties naturally because
of their laissez-faire attitude towards
death and destruction as well as their
commitment to making sure their unique
anarch is seen by the world are we cool
yet is actively despised by the SCP
Foundation the global occult Coalition
the FBI's unusual incidence unit and the
Horizon initiative confirm members are
to be arrested contained and questioned
for further information on site Dr
wondertainment is a lot more amicable
with members of arw cool yet after all a
lot of artists aren't quite able to pay
their bills on their passion projects
alone and as much as the starving artist
is a romanticized concept these people
do still really need to eat so there are
definitely worse things as an aspiring
and artist can do than take up a
part-time design job with the fine folks
at the Dr wondertainment toy company
they utilize their inherent creativity
and anomaly making skills of these
desperate and artists to create their
most delightfully devilish toys yet and
there's no shame in that after all
Salvador Dali did some work with Disney
and designed candy logos we all have our
side gigs members and cells of are we
cool yet have also documented links to
some of the more powerful and dangerous
group of Interest out there on the more
mild side of this new Spectrum there's
hansarp a German dottest and nihilist
group that was formed by members of are
we cool yet under the instructions of
the Church of the broken god-affiliated
leader Boris Alderman we may need to
give a little extra context here Dada or
dadaism to give a brief and highly
reductive definition is an early 20th
century art movement formed in the wake
of the horrors of world war one which
highly approved of War violence and
nationalism it sought to challenge the
very boundaries of Art and what could
really be considered art in the first
place so naturally it has a lot of
common philosophical ground with the
loose Central ethos of the are we cool
yet movement annualism is in short the
belief in the lack of any inherent
meaning in life so it goes without
saying that hand sharp are some pretty
intense folks but not nearly intense as
Grand karcissist ion or the Scarlet King
and cells of our week cool yet have been
associated with both the sarkists and
the Scarlet King worshipers however
their relationship with some of the
sarcasts they've dealt with have been
Frosty to say the least for example in
scp-2714 an anomalous copy of The
Adventures of Tintin graphic novel
members of are we cool yet tricked a
sarcast into trapping one of his holy
figures in the comic book before killing
the forceps father a lot of creators
suffer for their art but the really
unpleasant folks make other people
suffer for their art and are we cool yet
has plenty of those another are we cool
yet cell known as cool yet radio which
focused on making audio-based anomalous
art pieces created
scp-4150 a version of the classic
Beatles song Penny Lane with a Cognito
hazardous effect added intriguingly this
song contains a lyric referencing the
seventh King which is believed to be a
nod to you guessed it the ever
unpleasant nightmarish chaos God the
Scarlet King there are truly all kinds
of members of are we cool yet covering
an extremely wide spectrum of beliefs
but I think we've heard more than enough
about the artists for now how about
instead we have our own little Sol new
devenu Magnifique exhibition right here
and take a look at some of are we cool
yet's finest pieces of anomalous art of
course the non-anomalous world is no
stranger to dangerous and provocative
art pieces performance artist Marina
Abramovic put herself in real danger by
involving knives and guns in her
performance piece Rhythm zero and Ron
athy put himself at the mercy of a wig
full of needles to raise awareness of
HIV in his peace self-obliteration but
no non-anomalous art piece will ever be
as deadly as
SCP-173 that's right the sculpture is
heavily theorized to be a piece of
deadly an art created by a powerful and
artist known as the sculptor it's
believed to be a commentary on the
nature of humanity itself an attention
seeker who only knows how to commit
violence and defecate for something a
little less deadly there's scp-092 a
collection of 3125 CDs each titled the
absolute absolute absolute absolute best
of The Fifth Dimension this piece was
created collaboratively by the musical
group Fifth Dimension and a member of
are we cool yet anyone listening to the
album is forced to listen to every song
in a row at which point anyone who
listened will exclaim wow that was real
cool however the artist felt this wasn't
their finest work and turn themself and
the CDs into the SCP Foundation for
voluntary containment then there's the
commission piece
scp-2635 the Hot Potato this was
initially paid for by a chechnyan rebel
group planning to take out their Russian
enemies and the an artist taking the
commission was happy to give it a
theatrical and artistic Flair any group
that possesses the potato for more than
one calendar year will lose half of its
members as they begin to spontaneously
combust to keep these effects from
occurring it's continually passed
between groups living up to its nickname
as the Hot Potato some great art can
come out of spite a good example is
scp-4879 a soapstone polar bear statue
that has the frightening ability to take
away the special talents of anyone
standing in its proximity it was created
by an an artist filled with spite of the
success and talent of his fellow artists
and wished to take away their artistic
spark however in what seems like a
meditation on the ultimately
self-destructive nature of spite the
very creation of scp-487 99 wound up
forever squashing whatever creative
abilities its creator had then we have
this little anomalous art tasterplate
the nightmare inducing
scp-1057 a kind of anti-shadow a
selectively tangible shape that despite
technically not being there can behave
and kill like an adult tiger shark and
to make things even more frightening
this Beast was first found after it
devoured people in an otherwise normal
swimming pool a note left by the
anti-shark's Creator on the swimming
pool's bulletin board red Panic means
that the idea of a shark can be more
dangerous than an actual shock it can be
even more dangerous than no shock at all
are we cool yet and we're sure that
means something there you have it folks
our crash course on the SCP foundation's
most artistic enemy the are we cool yet
Collective and look we're not saying
that the chaos Insurgency are nice
people but they at least just have the
decency to not tell us we don't like
their murderous sight raids because we
just don't get it and the tiny
carnivorous snowmen are Relentless sharp
fangs dripping with blood as they crawl
on mass towards the mobile task force
opening fire on them with their assault
rifles who would have guessed that a
mere hour or two earlier a young boy was
joyfully playing around in the snow here
how had things gone from Frosty to
freaky so fast let's rewind the clock
there was a chill in the air that
lingering biting coal that would gnaw in
your Exposed Skin if you dare to step
outside in anything less than a thick
warm coat for protection the ground was
still coated in a heavy snowfall a
holdover from Christmas just passed
whether that had refused to let up well
into the early days of the New Year
everyone reaches an age where the
cynicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coalesce to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
novelty it becomes a source of
convenience something that you need to
shovel off the driveway to take your car
out whereas turn the clock back to Youth
and it's like a tiny Miracle It Coats
your whole world in a clean blanket of
freezing Frost turning the ordinary into
a Wonderland Robert and Michaela
Anderson were glad that their son
Michael was still at an age where he
could enjoy the snow after all Michaela
getting to take her son out in a sled or
seeing him hurling snowballs at Robert
was able to provide them with a little
bit of warmth during the freezing cold
snowier months in Missouri optimism was
never enough to melt the snow however
then maybe that's what drew in those
creatures the snowmen it was early 2019
not even a full two weeks into the Year
by now Michael had gotten used to the
fact that after Christmas and New Year's
Day a begrudging return to school would
soon follow as much as it clearly
brought down his mood nothing lifted his
spirits like like still getting to be
out in the snow and after a long day of
helping his mom take down the tinsel and
pack up the lights while his dad
disposed of the tree Michael was itching
to go outside please Mom he begged as a
box of decorations was placed back in
the attic his hands clashed together in
a pleading gesture please please please
just five minutes I will go further than
the front yard Michaela sighed partly
from exhaustion but a smile crept onto
her face it was hard not to find her
son's love for the snow endearing all
right but only for five minutes she
insisted firmly and I want to see gloves
hat and a scarf not just a coat Mister
with the speed and excitement that she
and her husband had long since lost she
watched Michael race off to gather his
warmest winter coat remember when we
were like that Robert Eve decides he
appeared from chopping up that dried out
dehydrated remains of the Christmas tree
no do you Michaela replied with a light
chuckle before long Michael had donned
his gloves and coat almost a size too
big his scarf was almost wrapping up his
entire head save for the little bobble
head that poked out at the top Robert
opened up the front door and his son
stepped out into a world that had been
whitewashed with clear cold snow given
that the Andersons lived on a small
Street in Grain Valley there weren't
many other people around especially not
with another flurry of snowfall moving
closer in the clouds up above but it
wasn't the next snowfall that the
residents of Grain Valley Missouri
should have been worrying about it was
the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he and
his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow embedded on
the roof shingles a few meters from the
front door stood a snowman granted that
was hardly a rare sight at this time of
year especially in the cold weather but
what was so unusual about it was that
Michael hadn't remembered making a
snowman recently his parents had him let
him out in the snow on his own since the
start of the New Year given how badly
the downfall and icy winds had been for
the first week of January sure somebody
else could have made it taking a pause
as they passed by the Anderson's front
yard although not Michael Nor either of
his parents had spotted anyone doing
that the Snowman itself was featureless
the white of its ice cold body smeared
with mud and Dead Leaves debris that had
been packed in with the snow used in its
crude construction it was featureless
too whoever had made it hadn't gone to
the effort of giving it a face nor
draped an old scarf over it or given it
a hat it just stood there but not like
any other snowman there was nothing
welcoming about it in fact it was
fittingly cold given how far away it
stood it was almost as if it was
watching the house curiously Michael
began to approach the Snowman being only
nine years old his imagination was
immediately running with the possibility
that this snow and mulch construct could
be alive much akin to the likes of
Frosty the Snowman little did young
Michael Anderson know that he wasn't far
away from the truth although this
particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he hadn't got that much
closer to the Snowman when he heard
something move nearer to where he stood
there was the rustle of leaves and the
Snapping of small Twigs coming up from a
bush next to him Michael couldn't see
what it was but it was far too low to
the ground and too close to the house
for it to be a bird maybe a possum or
raccoon had gotten trapped in the thin
branches and was now scrambling to try
and free itself diverting from
approaching the Snowman he walked closer
to the plant as he did the rustling got
louder more frantic almost hungry there
wasn't just one creature lurking out of
sight beneath the leaves but lots of
some things Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside in floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg be howled as
he felt searing pain bitten by Rose of
tiny pointed teeth as sharp as needles
and as bitterly cold as ice stumbling
back Robert Anderson fell over and
landed on the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michaela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get closer with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring into disbelief
and what had bitten him it was barely
more than half a meter tall a tiny white
snowman bulbous bloodied eyes bulged
from its head much like those of an
insect directly between the eyes was a
hole a mouth not unlike a lamprey lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it reared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in a display
of aggression that caused all three of
them to jump rarely backing away from
the snow future it was then that Robert
and Michaela noticed what had frightened
their son so much out of the corner of
their eye they both simultaneously
caught the sight of the open front door
and the yard Beyond wriggling through
the snow shifting as they moved were
even more of the creatures slithering
towards the house like piranhas catching
the scent of blood in the water and
standing ominously just beyond the
driveway was the Snowman as if it was
the General commanding its troops to
storm the house the Andersons raced
upstairs as the swarm of snow creatures
came spilling into the house crawling
from the yard onto the floor and piling
on top of each other like ants to climb
the stairs naturally Michaela's first
instinct as well as protecting her son
was to call the police while Robert Held
the door to the bedroom shut Michaela
held Michael close and pleaded with the
local grain Valley Police Department to
come and help them although they only
seemed to take the call seriously when
Michael started screaming again one of
the snow creatures had pushed its way
under the door frame and was sneaking
its way towards Robert to attack him
leaving a trail of water behind it
stepping back and Thinking Fast Robert
grabbed a hair dryer and switched it on
full blast the Sudden Rush of
electrically heated air caused the
toothy snow creature to retreat into a
corner refusing to let up Robert got
closer and kept the hairdryer trained on
it eventually causing the creature to
melt until little more was left than a
damp puddle but the victory was
momentary there were still more of them
crawling up the stairs after the
Andersons with their sharp teeth they
were gnawing at the wood of the bedroom
door trying to force their way inside
fortunately for Robert Michaela and
their son Michael they wouldn't be able
to recall the horrific events of January
12 2019 for much longer by the time the
local police arrived it had become clear
to the officers responding that they
were well out of their depth especially
when one of them was injured suffering a
bite from a snow creature that was what
led the SCP Foundation being called in
and within 15 minutes they had
dispatched mobile task force operatives
to secure the anomaly being some of the
foundation's most highly trained agents
it didn't take long for the MTF to
neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures however they quickly realized
that the mysterious snowmen that had
seemingly spawned the Swarm could not be
melted by any conventional means nor
would it deteriorate naturally on its
own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as
scp-4230 immediately the SCP Foundation
did it as their organization does best
and commenced testing with a human
subject no less they quickly discovered
that scp-4230 seemed to generate a sort
of field around itself that could
trigger a distinctive physiological
change in any human being or animal that
came within six meters of the Snowman
this process became known under the
designation of
scp-4230-1 it appeared that Michael
Anderson had managed to unknowingly
escape this fate purely by not getting
too close to scp-4230 staying just far
enough away so as not to trigger
scp-4230-1 the foundation placed
d-19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this six meter radius
of the Snowman and observed the gradual
changes he underwent over the following
week for simplicity's sake will refer to
d-19375 as frost a rather fitting
moniker and you'll soon see why within a
day of exposure to the Snowman Frost
complained to a senior base researcher
that he felt a lot colder than usual
although he exhibited no other
observable symptoms beyond the coughing
and sniffling of a common cold by the
following day Frost was far worse for
wear appearing to have lost significant
body mass to the point where he'd
appeared to have been malnourished his
cold-like symptoms had continued
accompanied by disorienting dizziness
and as if all that wasn't bad enough his
skin tone had seemingly lost its natural
pigment reduced to an unnaturally pale
shade as white as snow day three saw
Frost's body continue to change rapidly
at an alarming rate he was internally
producing an unknown chemical that
looked to be responsible for enacting
certain alterations namely the
dissolving of his femur and fibula the
cold and dizziness were also now made
all the worse by the addition of pain to
the man's lower body Frost even reported
to Foundation researchers studying him
that every movement he was able to make
caused him to suffer extreme levels of
physical pain but yet rather than
attempt to cure his condition the
foundation apathetically observed noting
down the process of
scp-4230-1 within five days of exposure
to scp-4230 naturally occurring
substances within Frost's body had
traveled downwards and solidified this
was followed by the most shocking stage
of the scp-4230-1 process so far and one
that made the foundation realize that
these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day 5 saw Frost's
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
scp-4230-1 began to take effect Frost
had started to secrete an unknown
substance this liquid lowered his body
temperature freezing almost instantly
and turning his skin into an icy white
Mass worryingly Sim similar to snow sure
enough on the Eighth Day the extent of
the scp-4230-1 process was made evident
Frost had already perished his body now
looking identical to a plain featureless
Snowman no eyes or face just a blank
cold slate but underneath the outer
layer of snow Frost's bones and the rest
of his organs were still contained
inside from the outside though he wasn't
even human anymore just an instance of
what became known as
scp-4230-a however being turned into
another Snowman by close proximity to
scp-4230 wasn't even the worst part by
now you might be wondering what were
those snow creatures that attacked the
Andersons you'd be forgiven for thinking
that perhaps these were rodents or other
wild animals affected by scp-4230-1
after all testing has shown that the
process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous needle
tooth creatures are known as scp-4230-1
and they are nasty little critters to
say the least when a person or animal is
turned into a snowman during
scp-4230-1 becoming one of these
instances is far from the full extent of
the transformation the test the
foundation conducted on Frost and
presumably on numerous other d-class
personnel as well led to them
discovering the further alterations made
when someone becomes an
scp-4230-a instance their freezing snow
encased bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an
scp-4230-a snowman these eggs will hatch
within 72 hours producing up to 19
instances of
scp-4230-b creatures the foundation was
quick to examine these bizarre snow
spawn Gathering up as many as they could
for testing they found that instances of
scp-4230-b matured to adulthood
remarkably quickly reaching adulthood in
15 seconds
destroying the eggs containing these
creatures seemed to be an effective way
of preventing swarms of
scp-4230-bs from getting loose although
the Snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve
this result also the lifespans of the
smaller snow creatures only lasted for a
total of 24 hours and they would melt
away after a full day of life regardless
of the surrounding temperature
scp-4230-b seem uninterested in food
that was presented to them specifically
one test involved giving a snow creature
a head of lettuce and a watermelon the
creature regarded the fruit and
vegetables with little interest even
refusing to eat either despite prompts
from the researchers this painted the
scp-4230-bs as exclusive carnivores
which explained why they attacked the
Anderson family they were trying to eat
them hunting the Andersons as a pack
further testing into
scp-4230-bs revealed they had a weakness
to heat above a temperature of 40
degrees Fahrenheit during another test a
d-class was sent into a cell with 10 of
the carnivorous snow creatures armed
only with a simple lighter an emergency
flare and one gallon of gasoline
immediately all 10 of the
scp-4230-bs crawled toward the man
hungry and determined him to be a new
source of food that is until they
noticed the lighter he was carrying the
d-class frantically clicked the spark
wheel until the flame danced from the
lighter causing seven of the creatures
to back away from the heat Source
cautiously the d-class was able to kill
the remaining three instances in
self-defense causing them to melt with
little effort he was Far luckier than
the subject of the next test would be
another d-class was placed in a holding
cell with three of the snow creatures
and much like before they instantly
acknowledged his presence and began
approaching him however the foundation
had sent this member of d-class in
completely unarmed without even so much
as a match to defend himself the
carnivorous beasts made short work of
their helpless victim feeding on what
was left the foundation was able to
dispatch instances of
scp-4230-b with relative ease even
without waiting for them to Simply melt
after a day the use of flamethrowers or
drawing them into warmer areas seemed
effective enough at destroying the small
snowman that hatched out of
scp-4230-a bodies however some bright
spark at the foundation decided to test
what would happen if the opposite
element was used against
scp-4230-b creatures were they
vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow-like substance
themselves another test was conducted to
answer this which involved a small
snowball being thrown at one of the
scp-4230-bs the result of that incident
has been entirely expunged from the
foundation's archives but it's a safe
guess to ask why evidently when attacked
using snow or ice
scp-4230-bs are seemingly able to adapt
in some way that is determined to their
attacker do they add snow to their mass
or become even more aggressive it's hard
to say give redactions but the result of
that final test were deemed so
catastrophic that the foundation banned
any further testing that involved
scp-4230-bs as for where
scp-4231st came from the foundation is
still baffled the first reported
incident involving the Killer Snowman
and the carnivorous creatures It
produced came when the Andersons found
themselves Under Siege by hungry
scp-4230-bs maybe the Snowman is just a
freak of nature or the result of an
unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in a snowstorm one fateful night
or perhaps
scp-4230 is something far far more
vicious whatever the case we would
recommend waiting for the sun to come
back out and the snow to melt just to be
safe you would think the smell would be
the worst part and don't get me wrong it
was far from Pleasant to say the least
that pungent odor a stomach turning
scent like raw sewage it was isn't just
dirt and Decay now it was far more
disgusting than that it had that awful
metal Tang to it that meant when that
awful stench crawled its way up your
nose it lingered hanging at the back of
your throat choking you on the sickening
wreath that lay thick in the air like a
foul-smelling fog and yet like I said
that was far from the worst part what
was well even the sight of what had
happened to him wasn't what made me feel
unsettled hardly any of his body was
visible covered in that writhing
shifting cloak but I could see it move
each tiny piece of the mass moving on
its own it made me imagine what it must
have felt like to have all those little
scratchy legs and Pinchers Claws and
teeth hooking into his skin and that the
idea of what it would feel like that was
the worst part about seeing the Vermin
God City life isn't really all it's
cracked up to be ask anyone who lives in
big urban area and they'll likely tell
you the same those bright lights and
Tall spiers reaching up to the clouds
they offer the promise of prosperity
opportunity and even Fame and Fortune
for those who are extra naive but when
they Up Sticks packed their bags and
moved here to start a new life they
realize that all along they had been
sold on a dream a false fantasy that is
just simply too good to be true of
course by the time they get here it's
already too late and before they know it
their knee-deep in debt trying to keep
up with paying rent on an apartment
that's barely big enough for one person
if you aren't careful a big city can
swallow you up sometimes literally never
mind just desperately trying to make
ends meet and keep yourself afloat
there's also plenty of danger to be
found in the Heart of the City it
doesn't take much for people to lose
themselves in the darker parts of this
Metropolitan hell pretending it's a
Haven and when they do that's usually
where my job starts I've been more
working as a private investigator for
coming up on a decade my specific job
title had gone through a number of
rebrands and different combinations of
terms over the years Cassius Duke
detective for hire then private eye and
freelance investigator after that and
don't fall under the same with sort of
assumptions that most people do when
they hear all of those terms believe me
just like the city's promises it rarely
lives up to what you'd imagined it to be
like my life was never high speed chases
and gunfights solving murders and
tracking down Crooks that rob banks and
clown masks that was work for the real
police allegedly much higher above my
pay grade now that I had quit most of
the time I dealt with uncovering the
various dirty little secrets this grimy
City had to offer more often than not my
job was working as either a spy or
enforcer that anyone could hire I
followed around the rivals of wealthy
businessmen snapping photos of them with
my camera to get any dirt I could that
my more unethical clients would probably
use for blackmail or I'd be warning
stalkers to keep away from whoever they
were causing trouble for usually with a
bit of gentle encouragement in the form
of some pretty Stern words and a wrap on
the knuckles of sorts it was ugly work
but that suited just how ugly the
underside of this whole city was some of
my clients were often desperate people
folks who the ordinary system of Law and
Order had found when that happened when
they had been turned away by the cops on
the verge of losing any hope they had
left that was usually when they turned
to me for help now I don't work for free
of course you get nothing for nothing
everything's got its price so on and so
forth but I wasn't looking to extort
people especially at their lowest
moments so firm but fair I charged them
a little bit for my time maybe a
finder's fee if I happen to come across
some dirt that was really worth some
extra cash it was rare for me to take on
a job pro bono as it were without
expecting any pay for my services
but when this case landed in my lap I
felt obligated to do the job for free it
was another gray day in a gray City a
knock on the door interrupted me from my
busy schedule of staring at the paint
flaking off my ceiling after I'd called
them through the person responsible for
that knock came stepping cautiously into
my office he told me his name was Martin
Jenkins but that his friends called him
Marty sorry I I don't really know how
all this works Martin admitted making no
attempt to mask how nervous he was well
why don't you take a seat first I sighed
that's a start oh okay they replied
awkwardly pulling up a chair and sitting
down opposite my desk saw Mr Jenkins
what can I Marty interjected Mr Jenkins
I repeated what is it that brings you
here well someone said you might be able
to help with my problem Martin said
sheepishly and what sort of problem are
you having Mr Jenkins I push for him to
give me a straight answer I didn't
really have a a lot of patience for
anyone who wasted time just getting to
the point it's my brother you see the
other Mr Jenkins he finally confessed
he's been missing it's actually been
months now the missing person's case is
a police matter I'm sorry but you'll
have to go to them as bad as it felt
turning the guy down at a time like this
I had my profession to protect if I
wasn't careful the cops would come down
on me like a ton of bricks I'd already
ruffled up some feathers in that area
not long before I'd taken a case where
and I'd accidentally photographed some
corrupt officers accepting bribes one of
those pictures wound up on the Evening
News there had been a Target on my back
ever since but detective Duke Martin
began to say Mr Duke I corrected him
I've already tried going to the police
they wouldn't even accepted a missing
person's case when I explained what
happened to my brother go on I said
reaching for my notebook in a pen on the
desk I left the city a while ago after
my brother and I Melvin his name's
Melvin Jenkins we we had an argument
and what was it that triggered this
argument I asked dragging my pen across
the page hey it was well a lot of things
Martin said our father died almost a
year ago it wasn't unexpected but Mel
took it pretty hard then the doctors
told us the condition dad had carried a
chance of being hereditary so we both
went to get tested I didn't show any
signs of developing it but Alvin did he
took it as a death sentence got very low
and started wasting all of our
inheritance on every Vice he could get
his hands on drinking partying gambling
you name it he was doing it and this led
to the argument I probed it did I
confronted him before I left town I was
mad that he'd been using all our dad
left us for such frivolous and
irresponsible things Marvin continued
his story almost unable to stop now he's
started he didn't want to hear any of it
said he was going to die eventually
anyway so what was the point and I told
him he was selfish and that was the last
time we spoke when did you notice he was
missing as soon as I came back from from
out of town he answered I went to the
apartment dad had left us that too along
with all the payments still due and I
found that Mel was gone apparently he
had better in a card game and lost badly
I had no way of finding him nobody else
knew where he was let me guess I stepped
in when you went to the police they said
he's most likely living on the street
which would make him a lot harder to
find Martin nodded solemnly clearly
feeling guilty for what had happened
although from where I was sitting it was
his brother's own misgivings that had
created this situation I went on to ask
a few more background questions before
asking if Mr Jenkins could provide me
with a photo of his missing brother be
obliged handing over a printed picture
the moment I saw it I offered to take
the case for free his brother Melvin I
recognized him almost instantly he was
in his mid or possibly late 30s average
height and build in the picture far
better shape and a lot cleaner than when
I'd seen him but it was that same guy
that much I was sure of no amount of
unshaved stuff level or disheveled
clothing could change that I'd seen him
seen Melvin outside my building a few
times sleeping rough on the sidewalk
every day that I showed up to start
another day of work I dropped him a few
dollars anything I had in my wallet at
first I told myself it was for good luck
so I didn't attract any bad karma for
myself but when I actually paid
attention to how he was living the
gesture became what it should have been
from the start it wasn't about me or
sparing myself bad luck it was just
about trying to help out someone who
needed it when I was in a position to do
him a small kindness at the very least
one night I just locked up my office and
I was about to head home as I stepped
off the curb Head Down Eyes on my phone
a truck came speeding down the street I
would have been killed instantly had a
hand not grab me and pulled me back onto
the sidewalk Melvin had hauled me out of
Harm's Way he didn't say anything to me
and I failed to do anything more than
just thank him verbally before heading
home so I figured I owed him one well I
didn't tell his brother this it had been
a few months since I last seen Melvin
outside my building I'd always assume he
moved on or been asked to move by an
overzealous cop of course that meant
figuring out where he was going was
going to be tricky exactly the reason
the police had turned Martin away when
he'd asked them for help locating his
brother but I had a few connections that
even if they hadn't seen Melvin might
have at least heard something or could
know someone else that had seen him it
wasn't a lead yet but it was a start Dee
was the head of the city's biggest
homeless shelter and a good friend of
mine so she became my first Port of Call
I showed her the photo of Melvin and
asked if he'd come to stay at the
shelter recently doesn't ring a bell I'm
afraid she looks somberly at the picture
sorry Duke I wish I could be more help
not on you I replied taking the photo as
she handed it back to me you mind if I
ask around see if anyone here recognizes
him to be my guest decent I spent about
an hour Milling around asking a few down
on their folks if they recognize the man
in the photo a few of them mentioned
they'd seen him around here and there
sleeping rough in a number of different
parts of the city but none of them could
give me anything concrete no definite
location I'd be able to search next that
was until one of them spoke up he was an
older guy but dabbled clothes and
unwashed hair with a thick beard who had
been craning his neck to try and sneak a
look at the photo when I'd been showing
someone else I seen him the man Clarence
said matter-of-factly you recognize this
man I asked to verify said I seen him he
repeated looks different now though well
that's to be expected I replied I don't
mean he's gotten skinnier because he
ain't been eaten Clarence said in retort
I mean that he don't even look like he's
human no more but what does that mean I
questioned looking back at the bearded
man in confusion Batman right there
stopped being a man no idea when or how
it happened but last time I saw him it
was already too late nowadays he's the
Vermin God I didn't really have much of
an idea of how to respond unsure if
Clarence was pulling my leg and
deliberately wasting my time if there
was some truth to this bizarre urban
legend at any rate it was the only real
lead I had so far albeit a tenuous one
at Best so I pressed the old man to tell
me where he'd seen Melvin of This Vermin
God as he kept calling it there's an
abandoned warehouse down on the
waterfront Clarence had explained I knew
the place he meant it used to be a go-to
for people who were sleeping rough lots
of us used to stay there but that's when
the pests got bad pests what kind of
pests all kinds rats roaches you name it
man just we were having to deal with
them the company that owned the building
sent cops down to clear us out told us
it was unsafe and we should move on it
was sitting there empty for ages so I
decided to chance it head down there and
see if we could start using the place
again but when I went to look he was
there waiting in the dark and he wasn't
alone he ain't ever alone they are
always with him all around him I chose
to ignore clarence's attempts at
unnerving me getting him to confirm once
again that it was in fact Melvin he had
seen my next call was following up on
this wild story so so I hopped on to the
next bus across town huddled together
with commuters holding on to ceiling
rails swaying with every turn of the bus
like we were meat hanging in the back of
a butcher's van I walked quite a bit
from the bus stop towards the docks most
of the area was restricted off limits to
members of the general public given how
hazardous it could be I wasn't concerned
in my line of work I usually had to get
into places I wasn't supposed to be
pulling a pair of wire cutters from my
jacket pocket I snipped through the
chain-link fence that surrounded the
warehouse Clarence had directed me to
the place wasn't guarded after all it
was empty lifting up the wire mesh and
slipping underneath through the Gap I
grabbed my flashlight and headed in the
warehouse was well and truly deserted
previously used for storage but now just
an empty space that was being left
vacant wasted and it's lack of use all
around was silence occasionally broken
by beads of water dripping from the
Skylight into a puddle on the ground
suddenly I heard a new noise a crunch of
something being squashed under the sole
of my shoe I lifted my foot and Shone my
Torchlight downwards looking to see what
I just stepped on it was a cockroach far
bigger and fatter than anyone I'd ever
seen smashed to Pieces underneath my
shoe I stamped the rest of it off a
little disgusted as how everyone gets
when they see a roach dead or alive
that's when I noticed another sound a
low dull buzzing my initial thought was
that it was electrical maybe a generator
that was still running I started
searching around for the source of the
sound thinking that if I could flip the
switch it might turn on some lights in
here that would make searching for
Melvin a little easier suddenly as I
turned a corner the buzzing sound got
louder it wasn't just closer it was
angrier more intense what was worse was
that I'd walk Direct into a cloud of
something or lots of some things tiny
flies were whizzing past my ears the
noise of their wings so close it was
almost deafening meanwhile even more
were zipping around my face landing on
my skin and rubbing their little
germ-coated legs together waving my arms
wildly I tried my best to disperse the
Swarm clearing a few of them away as I
tumbled into the next room my flashlight
clattered to the floor as I crawled over
to pick it back up blindly swatting more
of the insects away in the dark that's
when I saw him the Vermin god with no
light in the room only the beam for my
flashlight I hadn't noticed it at first
the second the light fell over the
writhing Mass it shifted as a matter of
fact it didn't stop moving not once it
was a seething assortment of vermin
mostly black rats their fur wet with
what I could only assume was water
straight from the sewer but there was
more worms huge spiders thick roaches
dropping off of the huge shape as it
turned it's stood up a mass of animals
and insects standing like a man
lumbering towards me creatures were
falling off with every step only to
crawl back in and join the rest I pushed
myself back on the floor trying to get
away from what I assumed to be a
horrific monster something controlling
all the rats and Vermin making them form
around it like a cloak of pure filth and
Decay the stench of it as well that foul
unclean smell hanging in the air and
lingering at the back of my throat made
me want to be sick it was so repugnant
that it kept me crawling back until my
back was pressed up against the wall
trapping me between it and the Vermin
God it leaned closer reaching out an arm
covered in Grime and cockroaches all
crawling over each other I turned away
and closed my eyes yelling out into the
dark for anyone to come and help a voice
said weekly I looked up at it panting
and shaking in fear with trembling
fingers I lifted my flashlight higher
right up to the head of the Vermin God
beneath the mass of rats crawling over
it and the bugs wriggling about below
them a pair of eyes glinted in my
flashlight's beam human eyes there were
eyes I'd seen before the same
hopelessness behind them is when he used
to ask for change outside my building it
was Melvin that's when I started to see
beneath the Vermin coating his body
catching brief glimpses of his arms and
chest just as one rat moved but before
another slipped in and took its place
his skin was pockmarked with bites and
scratches some fresh and still bleeding
others that had started to dry beneath
the shroud of crawling insects and
rodents his face had gotten gaunt coated
in the thick layer of dirt he wasn't
controlling these things if anything the
Vermin seemed to be using him as some
kind of host just as I edged a little
closer to him considering the idea of
reaching into the mass and pulling
Melvin free one of the rats bit me I
dropped my torch at the pain of the tiny
needley teeth piercing my skin and
started to feel more of them crawling up
my ankles I turned heel and ran all the
way out of the warehouse by the time I
was far enough away the rats that had
leapt onto me had crawled back off
heading back inside into their Vermin
God a d-class drag races through the
testing Zone screaming at the top of his
lungs and doing donuts a mime who was
also in the testing chamber stares with
disapproval tapping his foot impatiently
did we mention that the car is made of
spiders yeah this one is going to be a
weird one folks stay tuned for one of
the craziest SCP stories you've ever
heard Emily had always dreamed of taking
a trip to Paris but the opportunity
actually came to visit the city she was
overjoyed she spent her time exploring
art museums tasting the bread and cheese
and walking through the city streets
taking in the sights one of her favorite
things about Paris was all the street
performers as she walked nibbling on a
panel chocolate she delighted in the
antics of jugglers tossing colorful
balls into the air she gasped at the
feet of athleticism and Grace
demonstrated by acrobats and
contortionists she giggled that the
Absurd shows put on by puppeteers and
dabbed tears from her eyes at the sound
of beautiful songs played and sung by
musicians it became part of her daily
routine one night as Emily was walking
back to her hostel after a long language
dinner she found herself walking down a
street she had not encountered before
there was no one around except for her
it was a lovely moment of Peace but it
also struck her as a little bit Eerie
and she wished for The Familiar throngs
of people up ahead she spotted the
silhouette of another person and let out
a sigh of relief as she got closer she
could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret the white face makeup rouged
cheeks and red lips a mime a real
classic French mime she couldn't believe
her luck when he spotted Emily
approaching the Mind began to start
performance he began with a classic the
invisible box he felt around the walls
of the invisible box looking out with
exaggerated wide eyes and an open mouth
Emily clapped and reached into her bag
for a little bit of money she could use
to tip him after all he was putting on a
performance just for her he deserved it
she walked closer to the mime looking
for a place to put her tip she didn't
see one so she held up her hand offering
the money directly to the mime as he
took notice of how close she was getting
the mime began shaking his head
vigorously eyes wide and insistent she
didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her until it was too late dozens
and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face out from inside of
his clothes from his shoes pouring out
over the street and crawling up onto
Emily she tried to brush them off she
tried to run away but no matter how hard
she tried the spiders just kept coming
all she could do was scream in an
attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance Emily unwittingly came
across
scp-3247
scp-3247 is a humanoid entity standing
at approximately 1.7 meters in height it
wears a striped shirt and suspenders
similar to the Garb of a stereotypical
French mime as well as what appears to
be white makeup on its face and all
other Exposed Skin though these aspects
of its appearance seem as if they should
be removable the clothing and makeup are
in fact parts of the entity's physiology
and cannot be removed from its body this
is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form though it looks
corporeal and solid The Entity cannot
touch or directly interact with any
solid matter with one particular
exception there is a colony of spiders
living on and inside of
scp-3247 these spiders have officially
been designated as C
p-3247-a and are highly protective of
scp-3247 if anyone or anything attempts
to approach
scp-3247 in a threatening manner the
spiders will swarm the Potential Threat
as any Savvy anomalous activity
enthusiasts might have already gathered
these are of course no ordinary spiders
not only do they dwell on and in an
intangible mime but they have a peculiar
response to witnessing a human being
making specific gestures or pantomiming
activities when this occurs the colony
of spiders will form the shape of an
object related to the gestures which
they will then hold for up to three
hours or until given additional stimuli
that prompt a change in shape while the
spider colony is assembled into shape
they will be able to share some of the
given objects functions in spite of
being technically nothing more than a
massive well-coordinated arachnids as
for
scp-3247 it is either are incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent liming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively living props
scp-3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propless art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother
scp-3247 in order to better understand
the nature of
scp-3247-a foundation staff conducted a
series of tests in each tested d-class
was given a gesture to perform in the
presence of
scp-3247 then the research staff would
record the spider colony's response
during the first test the research staff
ordered d-11424 to attempt to get as
close to
scp-3247 as possible they did not of
course warn him about the spiders he
enter the testing chamber and approach
the mime who is pantomiming the act of
climbing stairs as the Mind pretended to
ascend an invisible staircase and d11424
grew closer instances of
scp-3247-a emerged to take the shape of
a staircase much to the mime's
frustration
scp-3247 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to d11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with
scp-3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him
d-11424 began to wave frantically at the
mime the mime simply shrug giving him a
look that said well what do you want me
to do about it at this point control
intervened instructing d-11424 to
pantomime some kind of activity
fortunately before turning to a life of
crime d11424 had spent several years in
a professional Improv and was well
acquainted with pantomime his performing
instincts kicked in and he leapt into
action he put a hand to his ear as if
listening to the ringing of a telephone
the spiders stopped their attack
responding immediately to his Q they
formed into the shape of a small table
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on
top the mime rolled its eyes in disdain
at the side of this prop based
performance but d11424 was on a roll he
crossed to the phone picked up the
receiver and held it to his ear hello he
asked out of habit he wasn't expecting
to hear a voice on the other line but
then he did or rather he heard the
approximation of a human voice created
by a swarm of anomalous spiders it
sounded a bit like a human voice sped up
high-pitched and squeaky speaking some
sort of gibberish realizing that this
was his moment to escape
d11424 placed the phone back in place
and promptly left the testing chamber
the spiders remained in the shape of the
rotary phone and the table for the next
two hours at at which point they
disassembled and returned to their home
on
scp-3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11424 would be the designated test
subject for all future testing with
scp-3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders
d11424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to scp-682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test
d-11424 knew what to expect from
scp-3247 for this test he was told to
pantomime playing tug-a-war with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pan pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves into the shapes of
a long rope one side of which was in
d11424's hands as well as a large
humanoid vaguely muscular in shape that
was holding the other side of the Rope
the spiders gave the Rope a sharp tug
causing d-11424 to lose his balance and
fall over the Rope slipping out of his
grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three
d-11424 was instructed to enter the
testing chamber and close his fist while
extending the thumb and index finger in
a gesture colloquially known as finger
guns sure enough as soon as he assumed
this position the spiders assembled into
the shape of a handgun d11424 was then
instructed to pick up the spider gun and
squeeze the place where the trigger
would be if it was a real gun and not
you know spiders a loud cracking sound
was heard when the E-class squeezed as a
spider shot out of the barrel of the gun
at high speed before smacking into the
nearby wall leaving a small hole in the
surface
d11424 fired several more times each
Shot firing an individual spider at a
pace that attending researchers
described as faster than a speeding
bullet after firing six rounds of
spiders at the wall
d-11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76
d11424 was ordered to hold his hands
together and wiggle four fingers on each
hand effectively pantomiming a spider
the research team was curious to see
what the spiders would do when presented
with a shape that matched their usual
unassembled form
scp-3247 who generally did not react
much to the experiments on its spiders
began shaking its head in mild
disappointment as approximately
640 spiders emerge from its body
dividing themselves into groups of eight
each group of eight spiders then joined
to form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point d11424 followed
his heart jumping onto the mega spider's
back and riding it like a bull at the
rodeo as the spider bucked and ran back
and forth across the room according to
official transcripts d-11424 yelled ye
ha throughout this part of the test
until the head researcher ordered him to
climb down from the spider and exit the
room he was reprimanded for his behavior
and warned that if he acted without
approval again he would be taken off the
project and reassigned to a much less
enjoyable position as one of the
designated eyes on SCP-173
d-11424 immediately agreed to comply
with future instructions during test
number 133
d-11424 was sent into the testing
chamber and told to Shadowbox he danced
back and forth across the cell doing his
best Sylvester Stallone impression and
throwing punches in the general
direction of the spiders in response
approximately 3 000 spiders poured out
of
scp-3247 assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer and began to attack
d11424 the mass of spiders conducted
itself at the level of a professional
boxer dodging d1142 Force hits before
coming back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut it before he
could defend himself
d11424 fell to the ground unconscious
and guards were forced to interrupt the
test in order to remove him from the
room and take him to the infirmary for
medical treatment after taking some time
to recuperate
d11424 returned to testing with
scp-3247-a it was instructed to mime
steering a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerged
from
scp-3247 arranging themselves into the
shape of a sedan
d11424 was then commanded to climb
inside of the spider car and see if he
could start it he refused insisting I'm
not getting in a spider car are you nuts
when pressed by control to comply with
orders he made a rude hand gesture I'll
let you guess what that was the spiders
began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed
gesture prompting control to stop the
test early to spare the researchers
sensibilities with strict guidelines to
avoid inappropriate or violent gestures
d11424 was sent back into the testing
chamber with instruction to try out a
variety of animal inspired gestures in
Rapid succession he formed one hand into
a fist and made a peace sign with the
other hand putting them together to make
a snail as he made his hand snail crawl
through the air the spiders crawled onto
the floor and assembled into the shape
of a snail in front of d11424 though the
spiders moved quickly at their usual
scuttling Pace once they formed into the
snail they slowed to a gradual creep
d11424 noted a shiny slimy Trail left
behind on the floor as the spider snail
moved he was asked to consider touching
it but refused simply stating ew no next
he took his hands and formed the shape
of a wolf's head howling at the moon the
research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head or
the animal's entire body they got their
answer as the spider swarmed and shifted
forming the shape of a full-sized gray
wolf the wolf padded back and forth
across the room before sitting down
lifting its head and emitting an audible
howl that sounded almost
indistinguishable from the real thing
next d11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other fluttering hands like a pair of
wings the spider separated into smaller
groups and came together to form
butterflies similar in size to a monarch
these spider butterflies began to flap
their wings and much to d11424 surprise
they took flight and swirled through the
air around him the d-class was so moved
by the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture d11424 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled away returning to
scp-3247 and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit the spider
rabbit hopped realistically around the
room twitching its ears and tail at this
point d11424 was instructed to offer
this spider rabbit a carrot he produced
a carrot from his pocket holding it out
in front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d-11424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go
scp-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber
located in the arachnid wing of area 12.
it does not appear to require food or
rest but it has been provided with a
television and a collection of silent
films for morale purposes instances of
scp-3247-a are fed via a fully automated
system that dispenses 20 grams of live
crickets every week should a Containment
Breach occur staff have been instructed
to find a way to make escaped spiders
take on the shape that renders them
motionless then simply pick the spider
claw stir up and place it back inside of
the cell it is unlikely that the
foundation will ever get an explanation
for where the intangible mime and his
merry band of spider performers
originated from but one thing is clear
they won't be performing in public again
anytime soon now check out scp-058 Heart
of Darkness and
scp-2427 a thing full of stuff